ALL RIGHT. THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON PUBLIC SAFETY IS SET TO BEGIN
NOW, JUST A HEADS UP. WE HAVE 19
BILLS ON THE CALENDAR. THREE ARE
ON CONSENT. SB 1021 BY SENATOR
ARCHULETA, SB 1040 BY SENATOR
OCHOA. BOGH, SB 1518, WHICH IS
FROM THIS PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE. AND I'D LIKE TO ASK
FOR A ROLL CALL TO SEE IF WE
HAVE QUORUM. WAHAB. HEAR, HEAR!
SEYARTO HERE. CROTEAU. HERE.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD. HERE.
SKINNER. WIENER PERFECT. WE HAVE
QUORUM. CAN WE GET A MOTION ON
CONSENT, PLEASE? SO MOVED. MOVED
BY. SENATOR SARDO, CAN WE HAVE A
ROLL CALL? WAHAB, HERE. I MEAN,
SORRY, I. SATO. SATO I. BRADFORD
BRADFORD. I. SKINNER. WIENER.
ALL RIGHT. CONSENT IS ON CALL.
YOU WANT TO WAIT FOR BECKER TO
PROCEED TOGETHER? NOT REALLY,
BUT THAT WAS KIND OF
.
YOU'RE UP. ALL RIGHT. WE HAVE
OUR FIRST PRESENTER, SENATOR
UMBERG. SB 910 AT THIS LECTERN.
AND I JUST WANT TO AGAIN REMIND
THE AUDIENCE AND THOSE THAT ARE
PARTICIPATING IN THESE
COMMITTEES, THAT WITNESSES WILL
BE SPEAKING AT THAT LECTERN,
BOTH SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION TO
LEAD WITNESSES WILL BE TIMED AT
TWO MINUTES. ME TWOS. WE ASK
THAT YOU LINE UP VERY QUICKLY
AND STATE YOUR NAME, YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND WHETHER YOU
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE SENATOR
UMBERG, IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
PRESENT SB 910. THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR,
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
I WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR AND
STELLA CHLOE, FOR YOUR HELP IN
MAKING THIS BILL A BETTER BILL.
WHAT SB 910 DOES IS IT
ESTABLISHES STATEWIDE STANDARDS
FOR COLLABORATIVE COURTS TO
IMPROVE PROGRAMING, DRUG
TESTING, MEDICATION ASSISTED
TREATMENT FOR INDIVIDUALS MOVING
THROUGH THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM. THE COLLABORATIVE COURTS
ARE A VARIETY OF COURTS.
DIFFERENT COUNTIES HAVE
DIFFERENT SORT OF VARIETIES. IT
COULD BE A DRUG COURT. IT COULD
BE A VETERAN'S COURT, COULD BE A
HOMELESS COURT, COULD BE A
MENTAL A MENTAL HEALTH COURT.
BUT THE PURPOSE OF THE
COLLABORATIVE COURTS IS TO TAKE
TYPICALLY YOUNG OFFENDERS AND
PUT THEM ON THE RIGHT PATH WITH
A FAIRLY RIGOROUS PROGRAM,
MAKING SURE THAT THAT THEY, FOR
EXAMPLE, PROGRESS IN TERMS OF
THEIR EDUCATION OR THEIR
PROFESSION OR THEIR JOB, AND
ALSO THAT THEY, FOR EXAMPLE,
RECEIVE DRUG TREATMENT. SO AT
THE END OF THE PERIOD OF TIME
WHEN THEY'RE IN COLLABORATIVE
COURTS THAT THEY FINISH AND
THEIR RECORD IS WIPED CLEAN SO
THAT THEY CAN MOVE ON IN LIFE
WITHOUT HAVING A CRIMINAL RECORD
FOLLOWING THEM. ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES, THOUGH, IS THAT WE
HAVE COLLABORATIVE COURTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THAT USE
DIFFERENT STANDARDS, DIFFERENT
METHODOLOGIES, AND THERE ARE
SOME TRIED AND TRUE WAYS OF
MAKING SURE THAT COLLABORATIVE
COURTS ARE MOST SUCCESSFUL.
THEY'VE BEEN DEVELOPED BY A
GROUP CALLED ALL RISE, FORMERLY
KNOWN AS THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF DRUG COURT
PROFESSIONALS, AND WHAT THIS
BILL DOES IS SEEKS TO
STANDARDIZE THE COLLABORATIVE
COURTS TO YOU AND TO, REQUIRE
THEM TO USE BEST PRACTICES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. AND
YOU DON'T HAVE ANY LEAD
WITNESSES. CORRECT I'M IT. ALL
RIGHT. PERFECT. AND DO WE SEE
ANY LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESSES?
SEEING NONE, I'M GOING TO ASK ME
TO COME TOGETHER BOTH IN
OPPOSITION AND SUPPORT. AND COME
TO THE LECTERN. SEEING NONE,
WE'LL MOVE THE CONVERSATION TO
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
SENATOR SATO WOULD LIKE TO MOVE
THE BILL. SENATOR, WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE, THIS IS
IMPORTANT, I THINK, AN IMPORTANT
INITIATIVE FOR CALIFORNIA,
PARTICULARLY FOR ITS YOUNG
PEOPLE AND URGE AND I VOTE THANK
YOU. WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
SATO. CAN WE HAVE A ROLL CALL?
SB 910, MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WILL HAVE A AYE.
SATO. SATO. AYE. BRADFORD
BRADFORD. AYE. SKINNER. WIENER
THAT BILLS ON CALL. THANK YOU,
SENATOR. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
YOU HAVE TO REPLACE YOURSELF
WITH ANOTHER PERSON. YOU KNOW
WHAT? TELL ME. YOU CAN'T EVEN
.
NHÀ. YOU'RE LIKE. CAN WE
PUBLICLY CALL FOR SENATOR
BECKER? ASHBY. MENGIBAR DURAZO
ANYBODY THAT WOULD LIKE TO COME
TO THE SENATE, PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE TO PRESENT THEIR
BILLS. WE START AT 830. WE'RE AT
ALMOST 845. WE JUST
.
CAN WE LIFT THE CALL FOR SB 910?
NO, NO. WE ARE. WE JUST WANTED
AN AUTHOR. WE'RE GOING TO LIFT
THE CALL FOR YOU. FOR. FOR
HAMBURG'S BILL. YEAH ALL RIGHT,
LET ME JUST DO THIS. SB 910, THE
VOTE IS 3 TO 0. SKINNER.
SKINNER. AYE ALL RIGHT. AND THEN
CONSENT, PLEASE. SKINNER.
SKINNER. AYE. THANK YOU. AND
THEN, SENATOR SKINNER, WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS.
LIKE, I'M NOT READY. I'M JUST
WAKING UP. NO WORRY. I'M AWAKE.
MR. SKINNER IS PRESENTING SB
1144, THANK YOU VERY MUCH, CHAIR
AND MEMBERS, IN 2022, I CARRIED
A BILL THAT WAS SIGNED INTO LAW
THAT CREATED REGULATIONS FOR
ONLINE MARKETPLACES. NOW, THE
REASON WE NEEDED THESE
REGULATIONS IS IF YOU STEAL
GOODS NOW, YOU KNOW, MAYBE 20
YEARS AGO, MAYBE ONLY TEN YEARS
AGO, YOU MIGHT HAVE SOLD THEM
OUT OF THE TRUNK OF YOUR CAR.
YOU MIGHT HAVE SOLD THEM AT A
SWAP MEET. YOU MIGHT HAVE
VARIETY OF WAYS TO, UNLOAD THEM.
NOW, LIKE ALL OTHER SHOPPING
STOLEN GOODS ARE BEING SOLD
ONLINE. AND WHAT WE FIND IS THAT
ORGANIZED RETAIL CRIME RINGS USE
ONLINE MARKETPLACE TO, IN
EFFECT, FENCE THEIR STOLEN
GOODS. NOW, THAT BILL WAS VERY
IMPORTANT. IT CREATED
REGULATIONS FOR HIGH VOLUME
THIRD PARTY SELLERS AND IT MADE
THE ONLINE MARKETPLACES VERIFY
IF YOU WERE A LEGITIMATE SELLER
WITH AN ID, WITH BUSINESS
LICENSE, VARIOUS THINGS LIKE
THAT. NOW, WHAT WE'VE SEEN SINCE
THEN IS THAT PEOPLE ARE GETTING
AROUND THOSE REGULATIONS BY
USING MARKETPLACES WHERE THE
ACTUAL SALES TRANSACTION DOES
NOT HAPPEN ON THE MARKETPLACE.
YOU USE THE MARKETPLACE TO
ADVERTISE THE GOOD, BUT THEN YOU
DO THE TRANSACTION SEPARATELY.
SO SO WHAT 1144 DOES TO TRY TO,
IN EFFECT, LIMIT THE SALE OF
STOLEN GOODS ON THE ONLINE
MARKETPLACES IS IT ENSURES THAT
HIGH VOLUME THIRD PARTY SELLERS
MUST COMPLY WITH THE LAW SO IT
MAKES THE MARKETPLACE, CHECK
THEM. IT REQUIRES THE ONLINE
MARKETPLACES TO TAKE ACTION
AGAINST SELLERS WHO SELL STOLEN
GOODS. IT HAS THE ONLINE
MARKETPLACE DISCLOSED TO THE
CONSUMER THE BUYER WHEN A HIGH
VOLUME SELLER HAS COMPLIED WITH
REQUIREMENTS. SO, YOU KNOW, AS
THE BUYER, YOU HAVE SOME
CONFIDENCE THAT YOU'RE NOT
BUYING STOLEN GOODS, AND IT
EXPANDS THE CIVIL ENFORCEMENT
AUTHORITY OF DOJ TO INCLUDE
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS, CITY
ATTORNEYS AND CITY COUNCILS TO
FURTHER TARGET THESE ONLINE,
RETAIL CRIME RINGS. SO LET ME,
HAVE CHRISTINE SOTO DEBERRY, MY,
WITNESS, TO COME FORWARD. SHE'S
FROM THE PROSECUTOR'S ALLIANCE
OF CALIFORNIA. GOOD MORNING.
CHAIR. COMMITTEE MEMBERS. THANK
YOU FOR HAVING US. I'M CHRISTINE
SOTO DEBERRY. I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE PROSECUTORS
ALLIANCE. WE HAVE OVER 4000
MEMBERS ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. PROSECUTORS VICTIM
ADVOCATES, COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
AND WE ADVOCATE FOR SMART
SOLUTIONS TO CRIMINAL JUSTICE
ISSUES. WE ARE SPONSORING AND
PROUD TO WORK WITH SENATOR
SKINNER ON SB 1144, BECAUSE WE
BELIEVE IT IS A SMART APPROACH
TO SOME OF THE ISSUES WE'RE
FACING IN CALIFORNIA AND,
FRANKLY, AROUND THIS COUNTRY,
AROUND RETAIL THEFT. WE'VE ALL
BEEN EXPOSED TO VIDEOS OF PEOPLE
RUNNING INTO STORES AND SMASHING
CABINETS AND GRABBING MASSIVE
AMOUNTS OF GOODS. THIS BILL WILL
HELP US ELIMINATE BOTH THE
INCENTIVE AND THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR THOSE CRIMES TO OCCUR.
IMPORTANT PREVENTATIVE MEASURES,
RATHER THAN REACTIVE MEASURES
THAT MANY OF OUR RESPONSES IN
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM RELY
ON, AS SENATOR SKINNER INDICATED
, ALL THAT THIS WILL DO IS SOME
SIMPLE REQUIREMENTS ON ONLINE
MARKETPLACES. THESE ARE NOW OUR
CENTERS OF COMMERCE. THEY RIVAL
OUR BRICK AND MORTAR
ESTABLISHMENT. AND SIMILAR TO
REGULATIONS WE'VE PLACED ON
BRICK AND MORTAR PAWN SHOPS, WE
ARE NOW ASKING TO HAVE SIMILAR
REGULATIONS IN THE ONLINE
MARKETPLACE SPACE TO HELP US
ENSURE THAT THE COMMERCE THAT IS
HAPPENING THERE IS LEGITIMATE,
THAT THE GOODS THAT ARE BEING
SOLD, THAT WE ARE ALL PURCHASING
ARE APPROPRIATELY THERE, AND
THAT WE HAVE THE INFORMATION TO
UNDERSTAND WHEN WE'RE BUYING
LEGALLY ACQUIRED GOODS OR
ILLEGALLY ACQUIRED GOODS, WE
THINK THIS IS A SMART APPROACH.
IT COMPLEMENTS MANY OF THE OTHER
EFFORTS THAT ARE BEING
CONTEMPLATED BY THIS LEGISLATURE
AND THIS COMMITTEE AND OTHERS,
AND JUST A REMINDER THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT VERY LARGE
BUSINESSES AND VERY MODEST
REGULATIONS OF HOW THEY PERFORM
THEIR ONLINE BUSINESS. WE WOULD
ENCOURAGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE
SMART PREVENTATIVE MEASURE AND
ENCOURAGING COMMERCE, PRIVATE
SECTOR, LARGE COMPANIES TO JOIN
PROSECUTORS, POLICE AND ALL OF
YOU IN HELPING US PROTECT
CONSUMERS, COMMERCE AND PUBLIC
SAFETY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
RIVAS DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER LEAD
WITNESSES? NO. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU, DO WE HAVE LEAD OPPOSITION?
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS, DYLAN HOFFMAN
, ON BEHALF OF TECHNET, WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO SB 1144.
WHILE WE APPRECIATE THE MARCH
19TH AMENDMENTS, THEY DON'T
IMPACT SOME OF OUR MAIN CONCERNS
WITH THE BILL, WHICH IS THAT IT
CREATES A SEPARATE NEW
REQUIREMENTS FOR BUSINESSES
HOPING TO SELL IN CALIFORNIA AND
TAKES IT OUT OF ALIGNMENT WITH
THE REST OF THE COUNTRY, TECHNET
AND OUR MARKETPLACE MEMBERS TAKE
THE ISSUE OF ORGANIZED RETAIL
CRIME VERY SERIOUSLY. WE'VE
PARTICIPATED IN A THOROUGH
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS ORGANIZED BY
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL. WE'VE
TESTIFIED AT INFORMATIONAL
HEARINGS TO PROVIDE INFORMATION
ON OUR WORK IN THIS AREA, WE ARE
ALSO PART OF THE NATIONAL
NEGOTIATIONS IN 2022, ON THE
INFORM ACT, WE ALSO PARTICIPATED
IN THOSE CONVERSATIONS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA ON SB 301. WE DID NOT
OPPOSE THAT BILL. BOTH LAWS WENT
INTO EFFECT DURING THE SUMMER OF
LAST YEAR. THAT DEFINITION OF
HIGH VOLUME SELLER WAS THE
SUBJECT OF CAREFUL NEGOTIATIONS
HERE AND IN CONGRESS. IT WAS A
DELIBERATE POLICY CHOICE, NOT A
LOOPHOLE TO EXCLUDE OFF PLATFORM
SALES. THIS IS BECAUSE IT'S
IMPOSSIBLE FOR CERTAIN ONLINE
MARKETPLACES TO KNOW WHICH SALES
ARE COMPLETED OFF PLATFORM OR IN
PERSON, AND WITHOUT THIS
EXCLUSION, MARKETPLACES WILL
HAVE TO CONSIDER ALL SELLERS AS
HIGH VOLUME SELLERS IN ORDER TO
COMPLY WITH THIS LAW. THIS
BALANCE WAS STRUCK TO PROTECT
SMALL SELLERS AND THEIR PRIVATE
INFORMATION. INFORM REQUIRES
HIGH VOLUME SELLERS TO PROVIDE
THEIR NAME CONTACT INFORMATION
SUCH AS TELEPHONE NUMBER OR
EMAIL ADDRESS, THEIR TAX
IDENTIFICATION NUMBER, WHICH IS
A SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER FOR AN
INDIVIDUAL AND THEIR PHYSICAL
ADDRESS TO AN ONLINE MARKETPLACE
. THE CURRENT THRESHOLD AND
DEFINITION CAPTURES WHEN SELLERS
REACH A LEVEL OF ACTIVITY THAT
WARRANTS THAT PRIVACY TRADE OFF.
AND FINALLY, IT IS UNCLEAR HOW
THE REQUIREMENTS TO DISCLOSE TO
CONSUMERS THAT A HIGH THAT A
HIGH VOLUME SELLER HAS COMPLIED
WITH THIS WOULD WORK IN
PRACTICE, WE BELIEVE THAT SORT
OF A CHECK MARK WOULD
DISADVANTAGE SMALLER SELLERS BY
SIGNALING TO A CONSUMER THAT A
HIGH VOLUME SELLER HAS COMPLIED
WITH, AND HAS A HIGHER QUALITY
OF GOOD, WHEN THAT MAY NOT
NECESSARILY BE THE CASE. AND SO,
WE THINK IT DOESN'T MATCH
NECESSARILY WITH THE INTENT OF
THE BILL TO PROTECT THOSE TYPES
OF SELLERS. AND FOR THOSE
REASONS, WE'RE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED TO SB 1144. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESSES SEEING
NONE, WE'RE GOING TO GO TO ME.
TWOS ON BOTH SIDES SUPPORT AND
OPPOSE. PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
YOUR ORG AND THAT YOU SUPPORT OR
OPPOSE JAMIE MINOR ABOUT PASSING
ON OPPOSITION FOR A COLLEAGUE
REPRESENTING OFFER UP IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU. KRISTEN SCHLUSSEL
SACRAMENTO COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
ASSOCIATION, THÀNH, WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. PHÐ
MELENDEZ SMART, JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. SAXOPHONE
WITH THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA
CITIES IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
PAT ESPINOSA, SAN DIEGO DA'S
OFFICE IN SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING,
DEVON ANDERSON WITH POLITICAL
SOLUTIONS ON BEHALF OF TARGET
AND THE HOME DEPOT IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, DYLAN HOFFMAN, AGAIN
ON BEHALF OF A COLLEAGUE AT THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER, RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED. THANK YOU. ALICE
MICHAEL, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. SEEING NO OTHER
SPEAKERS, WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS. COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. ALL RIGHT. SEEING NONE.
SENATOR, WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
. THANK YOU. THE, I JUST WANTED
TO MAKE ONE LITTLE CORRECTION TO
ONE OF THE OPPOSITION THAT,
ARKANSAS NOW IS PURSUING A LAW
LIKE THIS ON, BEHALF OF WALMART
BECAUSE WALMART, THE REFERENCE
WAS TO THE NATIONAL LAW. INFORM
ACT THAT, SUPPOSEDLY EVERYONE
CAME TOGETHER ON, WHAT,
RETAILERS ARE NOW REALIZING IS
THAT IT DID NOT PROTECT THEM
ADEQUATELY. AND SO, LIKE SB
1144, ARKANSAS IS PURSUING A
SIMILAR LAW THAT WOULD ADD SOME
ADDITIONAL, REGULATIONS ON THE
LARGE ONLINE SELLERS. SO, WITH
THAT, I COULD GIVE YOU LOTS OF
EXAMPLES, LIKE THE RECENT COUPLE
IN SAN DIEGO WHO JUST GOT BUSTED
FOR THIS, BUT WITH THAT, I'LL
ASK FOR YOUR. AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU. DO I HAVE A MOTION? DO I
HAVE A MOTION? THANK YOU.
SENATOR BRADFORD MOVES THE BILL.
SB 1144. THE MOTION IS Dð PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS. WAHAB A
WAHAB. AYE. SATO SATO NOT
VOTING. BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE.
SKINNER. SKINNER. AYE. WIENER
OKAY. THAT BILLS ON CALL. NEXT.
WE'RE GOING ONE MORE TIME.
BECKER HERE, WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO SB 926, WHICH IS MY OWN
BILL, AND SENATOR SATO. YES.
SENATOR BECKER, WOULD YOU JOIN
ME? ALL RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO
HEAR SOME DUELING SENATE BILLS.
SB 926. SENATOR WAHAB, WELCOME
TO PUBLIC SAFETY THIS MORNING.
THANK YOU. YOU MAY BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY. ALL RIGHT, VICE
CHAIR, COLLEAGUES AND MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TODAY, I AM PROUD TO
PRESENT SB 926 SAFEGUARDING
AGAINST DIGITIZED
MISREPRESENTATION. SB 926 BUILDS
UPON OUR EXISTING REVENGE LAWS
TO ENSURE WE ARE CAPTURING
ADVANCEMENTS IN TECHNOLOGY AND
THE DIGITAL MANIPULATION OF
PHOTOS AND IMAGES. AS I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE,
SENATOR JOSH BECKER, FOR JOINING
FORCES ON THIS EFFORT, SB 926
ENSURES THAT UNAUTHORIZED
DISTRIBUTION OF NON-CONSENSUAL,
CONSENSUAL, SEXUALLY EXPLICIT
IMAGES IS CONSIDERED A
MISDEMEANOR, THEREBY INCREASING
LEGAL PROTECTION AND SUPPORT
SERVICES FOR VICTIMS AND
EMPOWERING THEM TO SEEK JUSTICE
AND ASSISTANCE RATHER THAN FACE
SHAME AND EMBARRASSMENT. SEN
CITY I STATED IN 2021 THAT UP TO
95% OF ONLINE DEEPFAKE VIDEOS
SINCE 2018 WERE NON-CONSENSUAL.
OF THOSE NON-CONSENSUAL VIDEOS,
90% ARE DEPICTIONS OF WOMEN,
WHILE THE DIGITAL MANIPULATION
OF IMAGES AND VIDEOS CAN IMPACT
ANYONE, INCLUDING, AS WE SAW
EARLIER THIS YEAR, SOMEBODY AS
AS FAMOUS AS TAYLOR SWIFT, IT IS
NOT FAIR. AND THIS IN PARTICULAR
IMPACTS WOMEN AT A
DISPROPORTIONATE LEVEL. WOMEN
ALREADY EXPERIENCE A NUMBER OF
DISPARITIES RELATED TO HOW MUCH
THEY ARE PAID. WOMEN HAVE TO
FACE WORKPLACE CONDUCT ISSUES,
SEXUAL HARASSMENT, AND MUCH
MORE. AND SO, YES, I PRIORITIZE
WOMEN IN THIS PARTICULAR BILL,
BUT AT THE SAME TIME, IT CAN
AFFECT ANYBODY. AND EVERYBODY
AND ACCESSIBILITY AND
UNDERSTANDING OF THEIR MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS. AND THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE VICTIMS OF REVENGE IS
DETRIMENTAL. SOME PEOPLE HAVE
EVEN WENT AS FAR AS COMMITTING
SUICIDE. AS ALL OF THESE ISSUES
CONVERGE ONTO EACH OTHER, IT'S
CLEAR HOW NON-CONSENSUAL
DISTRIBUTION OF DIGITALLY
MANIPULATED IMAGES CAN DERAIL A
WOMAN'S ENTIRE LIFE, LET ALONE
ANY OTHER VICTIM. SO I'D LIKE TO
INTRODUCE MY FIRST WITNESS,
DANIEL HÌ, DEPUTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY OF THE LA COUNTY
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE. BUT I'D FIRST
ALSO LIKE TO ALLOW FOR SENATOR
BECKER TO SHARE HIS, REASONS WHY
HE'S ALSO A JOINT AUTHOR. THANK
YOU. I THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING,
CHAIR MEMBERS. I'M HONORED TO BE
JOINT AUTHORING THIS BILL WITH
SENATOR WAHAB REPRESENTING
SILICON VALLEY. I WITNESSED
DAILY THE REMARKABLE
ADVANCEMENTS IN TECHNOLOGY,
HOWEVER, IS APPARENT IN
LEGISLATOR. I'M DEEPLY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE MISUSE OF TECHNOLOGY,
PARTICULARLY BY THOSE WHO ARE
USING GENERATIVE AI TO HARM
OTHERS. I BELIEVE THIS BILL IS
CRUCIAL THIS YEAR. THESE
SEXUALLY EXPLICIT NON-CONSENSUAL
DEEPFAKES ARE ALREADY BECOMING A
PROBLEM IN OUR COMMUNITIES AND
ACROSS THE STATE. AND I'VE DONE
A LOT OF STUFF IN LA BECAUSE
THIS HAS BEEN A BIG ISSUE. THERE
IN SCHOOLS, AND CURRENT LAWS
JUST DON'T, UNFORTUNATELY, DO
ENOUGH TO STOP THIS, LEAVING
PEOPLE OPEN TO EXPLOITATION,
HARASSMENT AND DEFAMATION. WE
URGENTLY NEED STRONGER LAWS TO
PROTECT PEOPLE FROM THESE HARMS.
I BELIEVE THAT SB 926 IS A
SIGNIFICANT STEP FORWARD IN
IMPROVING CURRENT LAWS FOR OUR
BETTER PROTECTION AND SUPPORT TO
VICTIMS. THESE IMAGES, BY
PENALIZING THOSE WHO SHARE THESE
IMAGES WITH HARMFUL INTENT. THIS
SENDS A CLEAR MESSAGE THIS
BEHAVIOR WILL NOT BE TOLERATED.
WHILE CALIFORNIA LEADS IN
TECHNOLOGY, WHICH IS GOOD, WE
MUST ALSO LEAD IN PROTECTING
PEOPLE FROM DIGITAL HARM. LET'S
ACT SWIFTLY AGAIN. I APPRECIATE
AND I'M GRATEFUL TO THE CHAIR
AND HAPPY TO JOIN IN ON THIS
BILL. I THANK YOU, SENATORS. AT
THIS TIME, WE'LL GO AHEAD AND
TAKE, WITNESS REYES IN FAVOR OF
THE BILL, YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
IF YOU COULD STICK TO THAT. MUCH
APPRECIATED. MR. CHAIRMAN.
MEMBERS. DANIELS, ON BEHALF OF
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE. AS THE
SENATORS INDICATED, REVENGE IS A
CRIME UNDER EXISTING LAW. IN
ORDER TO HAVE A SUCCESSFUL
PROSECUTION UNDER THIS STATUTE,
WE MUST SHOW THAT THERE WAS AN
IMAGE DEPICTING THE INTIMATE
BODY PARTS OF A READILY
IDENTIFIABLE PERSON OR IMAGES OF
THE PERSON ENGAGED IN SPECIFIED
SEX ACTS. WE MUST ALSO SHOW THAT
THE IMAGE WAS DISTRIBUTED BY A
PERSON WHO EITHER AGREED OR
UNDERSTOOD THAT THE IMAGE WAS TO
REMAIN PRIVATE, AND THE PERSON
DISTRIBUTING THE IMAGE KNEW, OR
SHOULD HAVE KNOWN THAT THE
DISTRIBUTION OF THE IMAGE WOULD
CAUSE THE VICTIM'S SERIOUS
EMOTIONAL DISTRESS AND THE
VICTIM SUFFERS THAT DISTRESS.
OUR OFFICE DETERMINED THAT AN
IMAGE OF DEEPFAKE REVENGE,
HOWEVER, CANNOT BE PROSECUTED
UNDER EXISTING LAW. THERE ARE
TWO REASONS FOR THIS. THE FIRST
IS SINCE THE IMAGE IS NOT REAL,
THE INTIMATE BODY PARTS BEING
DEPICTED ARE NOT THE PERSON'S
ACTUAL INTIMATE BODY PARTS, NOR
IS IT IF THE SPECIFIED SEX ACT
IS NOT REAL. SINCE THE IMAGE IS
NOT REAL, THE VICTIM AND THE
DEFENDANT, THERE IS NEVER AN
AGREEMENT THAT. OR COULD THERE
BE AN UNDERSTANDING BETWEEN THE
PARTIES THAT THE IMAGE WAS TO
REMAIN PRIVATE BECAUSE THE
VICTIM IS UNAWARE OF ITS
EXISTENCE? SB 926 WOULD CLOSE
THIS LOOPHOLE IN EXISTING LAW BY
MAKING THE DISTRIBUTION OF ANY
IMAGE CREATED OR ALTERED THROUGH
DIGITIZATION OF AN INTIMATE BODY
PART OF ANOTHER IDENTIFIABLE
PERSON, OR A DIGITIZED IMAGE OF
THE PERSON DEPICTED. ENGAGED IN
SPECIFIED SEX ACTS. UNDER
CIRCUMSTANCES IN WHICH THE
PERSON DISTRIBUTING THE IMAGE
KNOWS OR SHOULD KNOW THAT THE
DISTRIBUTION OF THE IMAGE WOULD
CAUSE SERIOUS EMOTIONAL DISTRESS
, AND THE PERSON DEPICTED
SUFFERS THAT DISTRESS. SB 926
WILL PROTECT VICTIMS WHILE STILL
ENSURING THE CONSTITUTIONALITY
OF THE STATUTE BY RETAINING THE
REQUIREMENT THAT THE PERSON
DISTRIBUTING THE IMAGE KNEW, OR
SHOULD HAVE KNOWN, THAT THE
DISTRIBUTION OF THE IMAGE WOULD
CAUSE THE VICTIM SERIOUS
EMOTIONAL DISTRESS AND THE
VICTIMS SUFFERED THAT DISTRESS.
FOR THIS REASON, WE ARE PROUD TO
SUPPORT SB 926 OR EXCUSE ME,
SPONSOR SB 926. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES, PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
FAVOR OF THE BILL? IF THERE IS
NO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN FAVOR OF
THE BILL, I'LL TAKE THE
OPPOSITION WITNESSES WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL. IF THERE ARE NONE,
WE'LL TAKE THE METOOS FOR
OPPOSITION. AND, FOR PEOPLE IN
FAVOR OF THE BILL, PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME AND YOUR ORGANIZATION
YOU REPRESENT. GOOD MORNING.
YOUR OPPOSITION OR FAVOR? GOOD
MORNING, TAMARA SCOTT, ON BEHALF
OF CRIME VICTIMS ALLIANCE AND
SUPPORT, AND Dð COONEY, ON
BEHALF OF ACLU. WE ARE NOT IN
OPPOSITION, BUT WE DO HAVE
CONCERNS THAT WE'VE ADDRESSED
WITH THE AUTHOR. AND THANK YOU
FOR WORKING WITH US ON THOSE
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU. IS THERE
ANYBODY ELSE? IF NOT, WE'LL
BRING IT BACK TO THE DAIS. ANY
COMMENTS FROM THE DAIS? SENATOR
SKINNER, I MOVE THE BILL. THE
BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
SKINNER. I JUST WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU BOTH FOR TACKLING THIS
ISSUE, BECAUSE IT IS A VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE, AND IT'S ONE OF
THOSE THINGS THAT AS WE MOVE
FORWARD IN TECHNOLOGY, NEW, NEW
THINGS PRESENT THEMSELVES, NEW
PROBLEMS PRESENT THEMSELVES, AND
IT'S A MUCH NEEDED, MUCH NEEDED
SOLUTION. THÀNH, AND HOPEFULLY
THIS WILL MAKE AN IMPACT ON
THOSE THAT, THAT THAT THINK THIS
IS OKAY. SO WITH THAT, I'LL,
I'LL ALLOW YOU TO CLOSE. YES
MISS. SORRY, SENATOR. SENATOR,
IF I COULD JUST MAKE ONE
COMMENT. SURE YOUR COMMENTS WERE
VERY APPROPRIATE, BUT AND OF
COURSE, YOUR PRESENTATION
ADDRESSED THIS, BUT I WANTED TO,
REFERENCE THE, OUR
REPRESENTATIVE FROM LA DA'S
OFFICE ABOUT HOW, I MEAN, WE
YOU'RE ADDRESSING SOMETHING THAT
THE, THE INTERNET, SOCIAL MEDIA
HAS UNLEASHED. AND WE KNOW
THERE'S MANY OTHER THINGS. AND
THESE. I DON'T KNOW HOW WE EVEN
CAN STAY ON TOP OF THIS, BUT
YOUR DESCRIPTION THAT OUR
CURRENT LAWS DON'T WORK. BECAUSE
EVEN THOUGH WE KNOW THAT THE
DEEPFAKE HAS USED SOME PORTION
OF AN IMAGE OF THE PERSON WHO
IT'S NOT THE IT'S A FAKE. SO HOW
DO YOU PROSECUTE SOMEONE FOR
QUOTE UNQUOTE DOING A FAKE? AND
YET WE KNOW THE DAMAGE IS REAL.
SO I MEAN, I DON'T KNOW, AGAIN,
HOW WE AS A LEGISLATURE ARE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO STAY ON TOP
OF TRYING TO PROTECT OUR
CONSUMERS FROM THE KINDS OF
THINGS THAT HAVE BEEN UNLEASHED.
BUT LIKE OUR MY COLLEAGUE HERE,
I ALSO THANK THE AUTHORS FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. SO WITH
THAT, SENATORS BECKER AND WAHAB,
YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU, JUAN,
I JUST WANT TO THANK THE DA FROM
LA'S OFFICE FOR SPONSORING OUR
BILL. I ALSO APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE AND THEIR WORK ON THIS
AND TO THE COMMENTS THAT WERE
MADE. YOU KNOW, WE'VE WITNESSED
HOW DIGITALLY MANIPULATED IMAGES
CAN GO VIRAL WHEN A CELEBRITY IS
INVOLVED. AND I MENTIONED TAYLOR
SWIFT BECAUSE LITERALLY MILLIONS
UPON MILLIONS OF PEOPLE LOOKED
AT THAT, MANIPULATED IMAGE
WITHIN A 24 HOUR PERIOD. AND YET
AT THE SAME TIME, A YOUNG WOMAN
IN COLLEGE, OR EVEN IN HIGH
SCHOOL DO NOT HAVE THE RESOURCES
THAT A MULTI-MILLIONAIRE
INDIVIDUAL HAS, ALL IT TAKES IS
FOR ONE YOUNG WOMAN SAYING NO TO
A DATE FOR HER MALE PEER. AND
GRANTED, I'M I'M HIGHLIGHTING A
SITUATION THÀNH TO TAKE THE
REJECTION SO PERSONALLY THAT IT
RUINS AND THEY CAN RUIN A LIFE
WITH DIGITALLY MANIPULATED NUDES
, CALIFORNIA IS HOME OF SILICON
VALLEY AND, YOU KNOW, TECH
INNOVATION. AND WE BOTH
REPRESENT SILICON VALLEY. AND
IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT OUR LAWS
AND I'VE SAID THIS A MILLION
TIMES, CATCH UP WITH TECHNOLOGY
WHICH IS MOVING AT A FASTER PACE
THAN WE CAN ACTUALLY KEEP UP
WITH. BUT AS POLICYMAKERS AND AS
INDIVIDUALS REPRESENT THE
SILICON VALLEY, WE HAVE TO TRY
SOMEWHERE. AND THIS BILL IS THE
START OF THAT. SO I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE. ALL RIGHT, MISS
SECRETARY, CAN YOU CALL THE
ROLL, PLEASE? SB 926 MOTION IS
DUE. PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WILL HAVE A
ACIERTO I THE ARTO I BRADFORD
SKINNER I SKINNER I WIENER.
OKAY. THAT BILL WILL REMAIN ON
CALL. THANK YOU, SO WE ARE GOING
TO, DOLLY AND THEN BECKER. OKAY.
SO WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
SENATOR DOLLY, WHO IS WITH US
PRESENTING SB 1267. THIS ONE GOT
PULLED, BASICALLY. NO, IT'S
AMENDED THOUGH. HE HAS TO
PRESENT THE AMENDED VERSION.
OKAY, GOOD. GOOD MORNING CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. TODAY I'M HERE TO
PRESENT SB 1267, WHICH WILL
UPDATE THE CDCR 1707 FORM AND
CLOSE A LOOPHOLE IN VICTIM
NOTIFICATION REQUIREMENTS FOR
CASES PRIOR TO THE FORM'S
CREATION. CURRENTLY, THE
PROTECTIONS GIVEN THROUGH
MARSY'S LAW SECURE AND SECURED
THROUGH THE CDCR 1707 FORM,
SERVE AS A VITAL TOOL FOR
VICTIMS TO REQUEST PROPER
NOTIFICATION FROM CDCR REGARDING
AN OFFENDER UNDER THEIR
JURISDICTION. HOWEVER, DURING
THE PAST DECADE OF CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORM, THERE HAS BEEN
SEVERAL CHANGES IN
POST-CONVICTION CONSIDERATIONS,
SUCH AS EARLY RELEASE,
RESENTENCING CHANGE TO PAROLE
CONSIDERATIONS, AND MORE. THE
CURRENT CDCR 700 AND 1707 FORM
DOES NOT REFLECT CHANGES IN
THESE CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM
POLICIES. FURTHER, VICTIMS OF
VIOLENT CASES THAT RESULT IN
LIFE SENTENCES PRIOR TO THE 1707
FORM BEING CREATED DO NOT
RECEIVE NOTIFICATIONS. THIS
CREATES A SIGNIFICANT GAP IN THE
IN THE SYSTEM LEGALLY AND
LOGISTICALLY, LEAVING VICTIMS
POTENTIALLY UNINFORMED ABOUT
CRUCIAL DEVELOPMENTS THAT MAY
IMPACT THEIR SAFETY, WELL-BEING,
AND A SENSE OF JUSTICE. OUR
OFFICE WAS CONTACTED BY PLACER
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE TO ADDRESS THESE EXISTING
GAPS IN THE VICTIM NOTIFICATION
PROCESS. WITH ME TODAY, I HAVE
PLACER COUNTY DA, MORGAN GUYER
AND RACHEL WESP TO GIVE THEIR
TESTIMONY. THANK YOU. YOU GUYS
WILL HAVE TWO MINUTES. PLEASE
APPROACH THE LECTERN. GOOD
MORNING. IN 1986, MY LITTLE
BROTHER WAS BRUTALLY BEATEN BY
MY MOTHER'S LIVE IN BOYFRIEND.
HE DIED OF ORGAN FAILURE ALONE
IN BED. RICHARD WAS TWO YEARS
OLD. HE WAS A VICTIM OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE, HOMICIDE. I WAS SEVEN
WHEN RICHARD WAS MURDERED. AND
I'VE CARRIED THIS WITH ME FOR A
LIFETIME. FAST FORWARD. I BECAME
A VICTIM ADVOCATE AND 30 YEARS
AFTER RICHARD'S MURDER, I
ACCEPTED A POSITION WITH THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE.
PLACER COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE, THE CHILD
ADVOCACY CENTER. THAT'S WHERE I
LEARNED ABOUT MY VICTIMS RIGHTS.
AND I COMPLETED A 17 BY 1707
FORM THAT REGISTERED ME WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS. SHORTLY AFTER THAT,
I ORDERED EVERY TRANSCRIPT OVER
THE LAST 30 YEARS FROM EVERY
PAROLE HEARING. AND I WAS
HEARTBROKEN TO KNOW THAT NOBODY
WAS THERE TO BE MY BROTHER'S
VOICE AND TO KNOW THAT IT ON
PAPER, IT SHOWED THAT NOBODY
CARED. I CARED, AND I LOVE HIM,
AND I ADVOCATE FOR HIM. YOU SEE,
WHEN RICHARD DIED, WHEN RICHARD
WAS MURDERED, THERE WAS NO 1707
FORM. THERE WERE NO VICTIMS
RIGHTS, THERE WAS NO
NOTIFICATION ON. MY GOAL IN
THOSE PAROLE HEARINGS WAS NOT TO
DETERMINE THE OUTCOME. MY GOAL
WAS TO MAKE SURE THAT HE HAD A
VOICE THAT HIS FAMILY WAS ABLE
TO REPRESENT HIM. HAD I NOT
WORKED WITH THE PLACER COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE, I
WOULD HAVE NOT KNOWN OF THOSE
RIGHTS. I WAS FORTUNATE TO GET
CONNECTED. SO I BELIEVE THAT
EVERY VICTIM, EVERY FAMILY OF
THOSE VICTIMS SHOULD HAVE THE
RIGHT OF PROPER NOTIFICATION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. MY NAME IS MORGAN
GUYER. I'M THE PLACER COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY. I APPRECIATE
YOUR TIME THIS MORNING. SB 1267
WILL BROADEN THE CATEGORY FOR
NOTIFICATIONS FOR THOSE VICTIMS
AND WITNESSES AS WELL TO HELP
ENSURE THAT EVERYONE RECEIVES
THE NOTIFICATION IN SPITE OF
OFTENTIMES A CHANGING LEGAL
LANDSCAPE THAT ALLOWS FOR
EARLIER RELEASE DATES, THIS WILL
ALLOW THOSE TO BE THOSE VICTIMS
TO BE INFORMED AND ALLOW
WITNESSES TO BE INFORMED WHO ARE
OFTEN, TRAUMATIZED AS MUCH AS
THE VICTIMS ARE IN MANY OF THESE
CASES. SO WITH THAT, I'D ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT. SB 1267. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE ANY
LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESSES SEEING
NONE. CAN WE MOVE ON TO SUPPORT
OPPOSED ME TO AGAIN STATE YOUR
NAME YOUR ORG AND THAT YOU
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE STEPHANIE
HERRERA WITH THE EMPOWER AND
RESILIENCE PROJECT AND SUPPORT?
DEBBIE BOYD WITH CRIME VICTIMS
UNITED SUPPORT. MORNING, MADAM
CHAIR CARL LONDON, ON BEHALF OF
CRIME VICTIMS UNITED IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. THANK YOU. MY NAME
IS ANNABELLE VELASQUEZ AND I'M
WITH. ARE THEY ABUSIVE AND
SUPPORT? GOOD MORNING. MY NAME
IS REGINA CHÁVEZ AND I'M WITH
THE EMPOWER AND RESILIENCE
PROJECT IN SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING, TAMARA MUSOLINO WITH
THE EMPOWER AND RESILIENCE
PROJECT IN SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING. MY NAME IS CHRIS
DIDIER, A MEMBER OF THE VICTIMS
OF ILLICIT DRUGS IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ALICE. MIKE,
ON BEHALF OF CPA AND OPPOSITION,
WHILE WE APPRECIATE THE
IMPORTANCE OF VICTIMS RECEIVING
NOTIFICATION, THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION ALREADY PROVIDES
FOR OUR NOTIFICATIONS TO VICTIMS
IN RECEIPT KANSEN HEARINGS,
PAROLE HEARINGS, WHICH THIS BILL
REQUIRES. WHAT THIS BILL
REQUIRES IS THAT CDC PROVIDE
THAT NOTIFICATION, SUPPORT OR
OPPOSE. OPPOSE. THANK YOU.
CHANCE TO OPPOSE. YET SHE DIDN'T
COME. WHEN WE. WE'RE JUST IN THE
METOOS. SO THANK YOU. OH OKAY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MORNING,
MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS. RYAN
SHERMAN WITH THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION AND THE
PLACER COUNTY DEPUTY SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. SEEING NO OTHER
COMMENTS, WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS, ALL
RIGHT. WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. I WOULD LIKE TO
, BUT ANYWAY, THAT'S ALL RIGHT.
DO YOU HAVE A QUESTION? NO, I
DON'T HAVE A QUESTION. I'M JUST
GOING TO SAY THANKS TO THE BILL.
I'M JUST GOING TO SAY THANK YOU
FOR THE BILL, I DON'T KNOW FROM
THE VICTIM'S STANDPOINT THAT
THERE IS SUCH THING AS TOO MUCH
NOTIFICATION, ESPECIALLY IN
REGARDS TO THIS, I HAVE FRIENDS
THAT JUST WENT THROUGH THIS WITH
THEIR, THE PERPETRATOR THAT
KILLED THEIR FOUR YEAR OLD AND
THEIR FRUSTRATIONS WITH THE
WHOLE SYSTEM AND SOME OF THE
NOTIFICATION PROCESS. THIS NEEDS
TO BE OVERCOME. THIS BILL, I
THINK WILL WILL HELP IN THAT
ENDEAVOR, SO WITH THAT, I MOVE
THE BILL. THANK YOU, WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR SERRANO. CAN
WE HAVE A ROLL CALL, PLEASE? SB
1267, MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. WAHAB, A WAHAB,
I SATO. SATO I BRADFORD. SKINNER
HI. SKINNER. AYE. WIENER THAT
BILL IS ON CALL. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO SENATOR BECKER. SB
935.
GOOD MORNING. CHAIR MEMBERS. I'M
HERE TO PRESENT, 935. THIS WAS A
DIFFERENT BILL ADDRESSING A
SIMILAR TOPIC AS PREVIOUSLY. BUT
I'M PLEASED NOW TO BE
COLLABORATING WITH THE CHAIR ON
HER BILL. AND AS SUCH, WE'VE
DECIDED TO AMEND 935 TO ADDRESS
A NEW ISSUE. CURRENTLY, THE LAW
ALLOWS PEACE OFFICERS OR
HONORABLY RETIRED OFFICERS WITH
SPECIFIC EXPERIENCE OR TRAINING
TO TESTIFY OUT OF COURT
STATEMENTS OR OF DECLARANTS. THE
PROBLEM IS THAT NOT ALL PEACE
OFFICERS WHO LEAVE THEIR
POSITION UNDER HONORABLE
CONDITIONS ARE ACTUALLY RETIRED
IN RECENT CASE, A DETECTIVE WITH
OVER 20 YEARS OF SERVICE
RESIGNED FROM LAPD BEFORE
REACHING THE AGE OF 50, MAKING
THEM INELIGIBLE FOR THEIR
PENSION. THE RESIGNATION WAS
ABRUPT, LEAVING PENDING
INVESTIGATIONS WITHOUT A
DETECTIVE TO TAKE OVER, WE NEED
TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY AT A
HEARING. THE ISSUE AROSE WHETHER
THE DETECTIVE WAS CONSIDERED
HONORABLY RETIRED WITHOUT
COLLECTING THEIR PENSION. SB
3935 WILL ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM
BY ALLOWING HONORABLY SEPARATED
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS WITH
THE REQUISITE EXPERIENCE TO ALSO
PROVIDE SUCH TESTIMONY. AND WITH
ME AGAIN, I HAVE DAN FELIZARDO,
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE, LOS
ANGELES COUNTY DA. THANK YOU.
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES, MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS DAN FELIZARDO, ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE, AS
THE SENATOR INDICATED, OUR
OFFICE SPONSORED AB 557 CARNET
BACK IN 2005, WHICH ALLOWED
HONORABLY RETIRED PEACE OFFICERS
TO PROVIDE HEARSAY TESTIMONY AT
PRELIMINARY HEARINGS. THE
TECHNICAL TECHNICAL DEFICIENCY
THAT WE DISCOVERED IN THE LAW IN
THE CASE THAT THE SENATOR
DESCRIBED WAS THAT NOT ALL PEACE
OFFICERS LEAVE THEIR POSITION
ACTUALLY ARE CONSIDERED
HONORABLY RETIRED, ACCORDING TO
THE SENATE LABOR, PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT AND RETIREMENT
COMMITTEE, THERE ARE CONFLICTING
DEFINITIONS OF WHAT IT MEANS TO
BE RETIRED. ONE DEFINITION
REQUIRES A RETIRED PERSON TO BE
ACTUALLY COLLECTING THEIR
PENSION. THE OTHER DEFINITION
ONLY REQUIRES THAT THE PERSON BE
ELIGIBLE TO COLLECT THEIR
PENSION, BUT DOES NOT REQUIRE
THE PENSION TO ACTUALLY BE
COLLECTED. IN ORDER TO BE
CONSIDERED RETIRED. AFTER
SPEAKING WITH EXPERTS IN BOTH
CRIMINAL LAW AND RETIREMENT LAW,
IT SEEMS THAT THE LANGUAGE IN AB
557 SHOULD HAVE INCLUDED A
REFERENCE TO HONORABLY RETIRED
OR HONORABLY SEPARATED PEACE
OFFICERS. SB 935 MAKES THAT
CORRECTION. WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU. DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER LEAD
SUPPORT WITNESSES? SEEING NONE,
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESSES. SEEING
NONE, WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
ME. TOS SEEING NONE, COMMITTEE
MEMBERS, WOULD YOU LIKE TO SPEAK
ON THIS BILL, SENATOR SKINNER? I
WILL MOVE THE BILL. THANK YOU.
SENATOR WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE?
THANK YOU. WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR SKINNER. CAN WE HAVE A
ROLL CALL, PLEASE? SB 935,
MOTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED,
TO APPROPRIATIONS. WAHAB, I, I
SEYARTO NOT VOTING. BRADFORD.
SKINNER I SKINNER. I WIENER. ALL
RIGHT. THAT BILL IS ON CALL.
SENATOR BECKER, WOULD YOU LIKE
TO PRESENT SB 1254, PLEASE? YES,
I WOULD. THANK YOU. MEMBERS SB
1254 IS A BILL THAT ALLOWS AN
INSISTS ASSISTS INCARCERATED
PEOPLE IN APPLYING FOR CALFRESH
BENEFITS UP TO 90 DAYS BEFORE
THEY'RE RELEASED TO BETTER
PREPARE THEM FOR REENTRY. BUT TO
BE CLEAR, THIS BILL PROVIDES
INDIVIDUALS WITH CALFRESH UPON
THEIR EXIT AND DON'T GET IT
UNTIL THEY EXIT THE FACILITY.
THE SUPPLEMENTAL NUTRITIONAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM, OR SNAP,
CALLED CALFRESH IN CALIFORNIA
AND SOMETIMES KNOWN AS FOOD
STAMPS, IS THE LARGEST FEDERAL
FOOD ASSISTANCE PROGRAM IN THE
NATION. AGAIN, TO BE CLEAR WITH
CALFRESH, THESE ARE FEDERAL
DOLLARS WE ARE DRAWING DOWN AND
UNDER FEDERAL LAW, INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS BECOME INELIGIBLE TO
RECEIVE CALFRESH BENEFITS. 90
DAYS OF AFTER 90 DAYS OF
CONFINEMENT. WHEREVER THE UNITED
STATES DEPARTMENT OF AGRICULTURE
ALLOWS FOR WAIVERS TO DEVIATE
FROM THAT CURRENT PROVISION,
WHICH 12 STATES HAVE ALREADY
DONE SO IN CALIFORNIA HAS NOT.
ORANGE COUNTY DOES HAVE A PILOT
PROGRAM OF CALFRESH
PRE-ENROLLMENT FOR INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS APPLYING FOR THE
WAIVER IN 2021. THEY DO IT FOR
EVERYONE LEAVING, AND THEY START
THE PROCESS 30 DAYS BEFORE
SOMEONE EXITS. AND IT'S BEEN
VERY SUCCESSFUL. THUS FAR. FOOD
INSECURITY IS ONE OF THE MOST
CHALLENGING HURDLES THAT
PREVIOUSLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS FACE UPON REENTRY IN
2019. ROUGHLY 1 IN 5 FORMERLY
INCARCERATED PEOPLE SUFFERED
FROM FOOD INSECURITY WHILE
CALIFORNIA HAS TAKEN STEPS TO
ESTABLISH AND CREATE A REENTRY
PROCESS FOR MEDICAL BENEFITS,
THERE IS A GAP IN CURRENT LAW TO
CREATE AN EQUIVALENT ENROLLMENT
PROCESS FOR CALFRESH AND A
STATEWIDE REENTRY PROCESS. 1254
BUILDS UPON EXISTING WORK IN
CONNECTING INDIVIDUALS WITH
STATE SERVICES IN AN EFFECTIVE
MANNER TO DECREASING BARRIERS TO
REENTRY, AND HELPING TO ADDRESS
ISSUES OF FOOD INSECURITY IN
CALIFORNIA. SPECIFICALLY, THE
BILL REQUIRES CDSS TO SUBMIT THE
APPLICABLE WAIVERS TO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO ALLOW FOR
PRE ENROLLMENT OF INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS PRIOR TO THE RELEASE
FROM STATE PRISON OR COUNTY
JAIL, AS AGAIN, 12 STATES
ALREADY DO WANT TO MENTION THAT
IT ALSO CREATES A WORKING GROUP
TO DEVELOP AND SHARE
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR A STATEWIDE
REENTRY PROCESS, INCORPORATING
ALL POTENTIAL NECESSARY
RESOURCES FOR AN INDIVIDUAL'S
REENTRY INTO THEIR COMMUNITY. TO
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS ABOUT
POSITION IN A PREVIOUS HEARING,
I'VE ADDED A SHERIFF OR SHERIFF
APPOINTEE TO THE WORKGROUP ALONG
WITH THE REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION. THOSE CHANGES CAME
AFTER OUR LAST COMMITTEE.
FURTHERMORE, THE BILL WILL
REQUIRE CDSS AND DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES TO CREATE
AND TEST A MEDI-CAL AND CALFRESH
COMBINED APPLICATION FOR
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS. SOON
LEAVING INCARCERATION, AND TO DO
SO BY OR ON JANUARY 1ST OF 2026.
THANK YOU FOR LETTING ME GO
THROUGH WHAT THIS BILL DOES.
REMOVING THESE BARRIERS TO
NECESSARY SERVICES WILL INCREASE
THE LIKELIHOOD OF A SUCCESSFUL
REENTRY FOR A PREVIOUSLY
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUAL, AND
MAXIMIZE UTILIZATION OF A
FEDERALLY FUNDED PROGRAM THAT
BENEFITS CALIFORNIA. WE PROPOSED
ONE CLERICAL AMENDMENT TO
FURTHER CLARIFY THAT THE
WORKGROUP WILL SUBMIT THE REPORT
IN AUGUST OF 2026. WE'VE
CONSISTENTLY ENGAGED WITH THE
OPPOSITION AND LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
CALIFORNIA WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION TO HELP ASSUAGE
THEIR OPPOSITION. AND WITH ME, I
HAVE CAMERON JONES FROM NORTH
CALIFORNIA AND ALYSSA MOORE,
LEGAL SERVICES FOR PRISONERS
WITH CHILDREN. THANK YOU. YOU
GUYS WILL HAVE TWO MINUTES. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR WAHAB AND MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE.
I'M CAMERON MIMS JONES WITH
NOURISH CALIFORNIA. FOR OVER 30
YEARS, OUR MISSION HAS BEEN TO
ENSURE EQUITABLE ACCESS TO FOOD,
HEALTH AND WELL-BEING FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. TODAY, I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT SB 1254. 1254 STEMS FROM
A RESTORATIVE FRAMEWORK AND
UPSTREAM POLICY TO DIMINISH THE
ENDURING IMPACTS OF
INCARCERATION BY ENABLING
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
ALREADY ELIGIBLE TO APPLY FOR
CALFRESH BENEFITS UP TO 90 DAYS
PRIOR TO RELEASE, AND
ESTABLISHING A WORK GROUP THAT
COULD OPTIMIZE RESOURCES.
CALFRESH IS OUR STATE'S BRANDED
NAME FOR SNAP, AS THE SENATOR
SHARED, AND HAS BEEN A LIFELINE
FOR MILLIONS TO PUT FOOD ON THE
TABLE. IT'S ADMINISTERED BY OUR
COUNTIES THROUGH THE STATE,
THROUGH OUR THROUGH OUR COUNTIES
AND IT STANDS AS OUR NATION'S
MOST EFFECTIVE ANTI-POVERTY
INITIATIVE, SUCCESSFUL REENTRY
HINGES ON TIMELY ACCESS TO
BASICS LIKE FOOD,
TRANSPORTATION, HEALTH CARE, AND
HOUSING. SB 1254 ISN'T JUST
ABOUT IDENTIFYING PROBLEMS, BUT
CRAFTING COLLABORATIVE SOLUTIONS
BY ESTABLISHING THE WORK GROUP
THAT WOULD BOLSTER A STATEWIDE
REENTRY PROCESS, THE BILL
ENSURES THAT MORE CALIFORNIANS
CAN ENSURE ACCESS TO THE
RESOURCES THAT THEY NEED TO
THRIVE. THIS LEGISLATION IS
ABOUT GRANTING ACCESS TO VITAL
RESOURCES AND OPPORTUNITIES. SB
1254 ASKS FOR THE FEDERAL WAIVER
TO EMPOWER OUR COUNTIES TO MEET
THE NEEDS OF OUR CITIZENS. WE'RE
PERPLEXED BY THE OPPOSITION'S
AGREEMENT ON THE MERITS OF THE
POLICY, AND WE HAVE. WE BELIEVE
WE'VE MADE ALL SINCERE EFFORTS
TO INCLUDE ALL WHO NEED TO BE A
PART OF THIS CRUCIAL PUBLIC
SAFETY WORK, AS DEMONSTRATED BY
OUR CONTINUAL NEED OF, YOU KNOW,
TAKING ON AMENDMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT ON SB 1254.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. MY NAME IS ALYSSA
MOORE. I'M WITH LEGAL SERVICES
FOR PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN, FOR
ME THIS IS A COMMON SENSE PUBLIC
SAFETY MEASURE THAT HELPS
ELIMINATE FOOD INSECURITY FOR
INCARCERATED PEOPLE PREPARING
FOR RELEASE THAT WILL ULTIMATELY
MAKE CALIFORNIA A SAFER PLACE.
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW FOR PEOPLE
LIKE MYSELF COMING HOME FROM
INCARCERATION, INCREASE ACCESS
TO CALFRESH AND MEDICAL MEDI-CAL
IMMEDIATELY UPON RELEASE. PLEASE
INDULGE ME IF THE COMMITTEE IS
UNAWARE UPON OUR RELEASE FROM
PRISON OR JAIL, IT IS ROUTINE TO
GO WITHOUT STABLE ACCESS TO FOOD
AND MEDICAL CARE FOR UP TO 7 TO
21 DAYS. AS WE NAVIGATE OUR
HOMECOMING, AND OFTEN MUCH
LONGER. THIS IN THE CURRENT
STATE ARE TRUE PICTURE OF WHAT
ACCESS TO EMERGENCY CALFRESH AND
MEDICAL BENEFITS AND VARIOUS
OTHER SUPPORT SERVICES. FOR ME,
7 TO 21 DAYS WITHOUT ACCESS TO
FOOD AND MEDICAL CARE IS A
SHAMEFUL REALITY THAT CAUSES
MANY PEOPLE TO TURN IN
DESPERATION TO OLD BEHAVIORS AS
A MEANS OF SURVIVAL. THIS BILL
WILL REQUIRE STATE, LOCAL, AND
FEDERAL ENTITIES TO COLLABORATE
TO MAKE THIS LEGISLATION A
REALITY FOR CALIFORNIA AND BRING
THOSE AFOREMENTIONED ENTITIES UP
TO DATE WITH TODAY'S
REHABILITATION STANDARDS AND
PUBLIC RECOGNITION THAT A SAFE
REENTRY IS A HUGE PART OF TRUE
REHABILITATION, WHICH, WITHOUT
THIS MUCH NEEDED LEGISLATION,
CALIFORNIA'S EFFORTS OF
REHABILITATION FALL SHORT OF THE
MARK. I ASK YOU, DOES IT MAKE
SENSE TO INVEST WHAT IS ASSUMED
TO BE THOUSANDS ANNUALLY IN
REHABILITATIVE EFFORTS INTO ONE
INDIVIDUAL AND THEN UPON PAROLE,
GIVE THEM NO TRUE OPPORTUNITY,
NOT TO REOFFEND FOR NEED OF
BASIC FOOD OR MEDICAL CARE. I
ASK YOU, WHO AMONG US CAN GO 7
TO 21 DAYS WITHOUT THE BASICS?
THANK YOU, WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO LEAD OPPOSITION. GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR. AND.
MEMBERS AS, AMANDA KIRCHNER WITH
QUDAH. WE HAVE BEEN IN ONGOING
AND FRUITFUL CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE SENATOR. OUR OPPOSITION IS
NOT WITH THE UNDERLYING POLICY,
WITH PROVIDING OUR SNAP
BENEFITS, BUT WE DO HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT LAYERING THIS
IMPLEMENTATION OVER THE ONGOING
IMPLEMENTATION WITH OUR CAL AIM,
INITIATIVE FOR THE JUSTICE
INVOLVED, POPULATIONS FOR
MEDI-CAL. WE HAVE NOT COMPLETED
THAT YET. IT WON'T BE COMPLETED
TILL THE END OF THIS YEAR,
POSSIBLY RUNNING INTO NEXT YEAR.
WE ALSO THINK THE BILL JUST
NEEDS TO BE RESTRUCTURED A
LITTLE BIT SO THAT WE CAN ENSURE
THAT WE HAVE THE WAIVER BEFORE
WE START DOING THE REST OF THE
AUTOMATION WORK THAT WE NEED TO
DO FOR OUR COMPUTER SYSTEMS TO
ALLOW FOR THIS POPULATION TO BE
ENROLLED PRIOR TO BEING
DISCHARGED FROM INCARCERATION,
AND THEN ACTUALLY DOING THE
WORKING GROUP TO LEARN FROM THE
LESSONS OF OUR CAL-AIM
IMPLEMENTATION. SO FOR THOSE
REASONS, WE DO HAVE CONCERNS,
BUT WE'LL CONTINUE TO KEEP
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR'S
OFFICE. THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS, CORY SALZILLO, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION, WE'RE
GRATEFUL FOR THE AUTHORS,
AMENDMENTS THAT ADDED A SHERIFF
OR SHERIFFS DESIGNEE TO THE WORK
GROUP, BUT WE REMAIN OPPOSED TO
THE BILL BASED ON THE REASONS
THAT WERE HIGHLIGHTED BY THE
PREVIOUS OPPOSITION WITNESS,
AGAIN, CAL AIM IS A GIANT
UNDERTAKING. THAT IS, WE ARE
RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE OF,
COUNTIES. SOME COUNTIES MAY BE
READY TO GO LIVE ON OCTOBER
FIRST. THE MAJORITY, I SUSPECT,
WILL NOT. THERE IS NO WAIVER FOR
THIS PROGRAM RIGHT NOW. THE
PROPONENTS HAVE POINTED TO A
PROGRAM THAT ORANGE COUNTY TOOK
ON VOLUNTARILY THAT, THE
PROPONENTS WOULD ARGUE IS
WORKING. WELL, THAT MAY BE THE
CASE, BUT IT'S MATERIALLY
DIFFERENT WHEN A COUNTY CHOOSES
TO TAKE ON A PROGRAM OF THEIR
OWN VOLITION AND HAS FUNDING TO
DO THAT, AND HAS THE
WHEREWITHAL, VERSUS THE STATE
LEVYING A MANDATE, SAYING, YOU
MUST DO THIS. OH, AND BY THE WAY
, YOU MUST DO THIS WHILE YOU ARE
TRYING TO IMPLEMENT A
MULTIBILLION DOLLAR PROGRAM OF
IDENTIFYING AND PROVIDING
IN-REACH SERVICES TO PEOPLE WHO
ARE WITHIN 90 DAYS OF RELEASE,
THAT THAT PROGRAM HAS NOT BEEN
FULLY FLESHED OUT, AND WE ARE
EXCEEDINGLY CONCERNED ABOUT
ADDING ANOTHER LAYER OF, OF THIS
BUREAUCRACY NOTWITHSTANDING THE
GOAL OF THE POLICY, TO THE
UNDERTAKINGS OF THIS THAT WILL
IT WILL IMPEDE THE CORRECTIONAL,
PURPOSES, ESPECIALLY ON COUNTY
JAIL SIDE FOR THOSE REASONS,
WE'D ASK FOR YOUR NO VOTE. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. I'M GOING TO NOW
ASK FOR SUPPORT AND OPPOSE ME TO
STATE YOUR NAME THAT YOU SUPPORT
OR YOU OPPOSE AND YOUR
ORGANIZATION. CHAIR MEMBERS
KATHY MORSBERGER, THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF FOOD BANKS IN
SUPPORT DUKE COONEY ON BEHALF OF
ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION LA
DEFENSA AND INITIATE JUSTICE AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, GAIL YAN.
WITH ONE REBOUND IN SUPPORT. ASK
MIKE ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION, IN
SUPPORT. JOANNA WILLIAMS WITH
LSPC STRONG SUPPORT. LAWRENCE
COX WITH ALL OF US ARE NONE
STRONG SUPPORT. PHªN PHªN WITH
JUSTICE AND AGING AND STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. ANDRES RAMIREZ, ON
BEHALF OF ALL HOME AND STRONG
SUPPORT. MONNING GILBERT,
ANTHONY MURILLO, LSPC ALYSSA
NUNN AND STRONG SUPPORT JOSHUA
STICKNEY ON BEHALF OF THE ELLA
BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS
AND THE PROSECUTOR'S ALLIANCE OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. RYAN
MAHAMUNI WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES.
NOT HERE ON OPPOSITION, BUT JUST
WOULD LIKE TO ECHO SOME OF THE
COMMENTS AND CONCERNS FROM THE
WELFARE DIRECTORS AND SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION ON IMPLEMENTATION.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT,
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SENATOR
SERRATO HAS SOME QUESTIONS. YOU
WANT TO GO FIRST? JUST YOU CAN.
OKAY NO. THANK YOU, SENATOR, FOR
YOUR, BILL ADDRESSING THIS. I
THINK IT IS AN IMPORTANT
COMPONENT OF SUCCESS WHEN PEOPLE
ARE LEAVING, INCARCERATION. AND
BUT ONE OF THE QUESTIONS I HAVE
IS ABOUT THE TIMING, BETWEEN THE
FEDERAL WAIVER AND IN, IN TRYING
TO INCORPORATE THIS PROGRAM,
DOES THE FEDERAL WAIVER HAVE TO
DOES THAT ENCOMPASS THE ENTIRE
STATE? AND YOU ONLY NEED ONE
WAIVER, BUT THAT'S GOING TO TAKE
A WHILE, WHICH IS AN UNKNOWN
AMOUNT OF TIME BEFORE WE CAN DO
THIS 90 DAY, PRE ENROLLMENT. IS
THAT WHAT WHAT I'M READING HERE,
IT IS ONE WAIVER FOR THE STATE.
OKAY. SO THE ANSWER IS YES,
LET'S SEE IF THE WITNESS WANTS
TO QUICKLY. I MEAN, THERE ARE 12
OTHER STATES WHO DO THIS. SO WE
EXPECT IT TO BE FAIRLY QUICK.
BUT IS IT OKAY TO HAVE MY
WITNESS COMMENT QUICKLY? SO THE
QUESTION TO THAT QUESTION, AS WE
EXPLAINED CALFRESH, THESE
INDIVIDUALS ARE ALREADY ELIGIBLE
FOR CALFRESH, RIGHT. THE WAIVER
THAT WE'RE SEEKING IS TO REMOVE
THIS 30 DAY, DISALLOWED MOMENT.
AND SO THE INDIVIDUALS WILL ARE
ALL ACROSS THE STATE CURRENTLY
ELIGIBLE. WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO IS START ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCESS PRIOR TO THEIR RELEASE.
AND SO NO ONE WOULD BE WAITING
FOR THAT FOR THE WAIVER. THE
WAIVER IS LITERALLY SUBMITTING
PAPERWORK. AND WE THEY'VE DONE
THAT IN ORANGE COUNTY. THEY
SUBMIT, YOU KNOW, WAIVERS ALL
THE TIME. AND SO THERE'S NOT A
WAIVER, RIGHT? YEAH. DO YOU
SUBMIT THE WAIVER WITH THE
PAPERWORK. YES. SO YOU CAN BE
FAIRLY CERTAIN THAT THE WAIVER
WILL COME IN TIME FOR YOU TO DO
SO, THAT THE ADMINISTRATIVE PART
OF THIS. YES THERE WOULD NOT
DOESN'T GO TO WASTE. YEAH, THERE
WOULD NO BE BEFORE BECAUSE IT
REALLY SOUNDS LIKE THEY'RE
THEY'RE VERY BURDENED, ON ON
DOING THE CAL AIM FIRST. AND I
WOULD PROBABLY SUGGEST THAT AS
SOON AS THAT'S DONE, THEN THEY
MAYBE MOVE ON TO THIS, HAVING
THEM DO THEM BOTH AT THE SAME
TIME, IS IT CAN MAKE THEM BOTH
NOT GET IMPLEMENTED VERY QUICKLY
AND, AND IT SOUNDS LIKE THERE'S
ALREADY STRUGGLES, SO THAT'S MY
CONCERN, IS THAT THE TIMING IT'S
NOT THE ISSUE ITSELF. IT'S THE
TIMING OF THE ISSUE AND HOW BEST
TO MAKE SURE, BOTH OF THOSE
EFFORTS SUCCEED, MAXIMALLY. AND
I THINK CAL AIM GETTING THEM
ENROLLED IN CAL AIM PRIOR TO
RELEASE IS, IS HAS A MORE, WHAT
DO YOU CALL IT, A IT NEEDS TO BE
DONE QUICKER THAN THE CALFRESH.
I THINK THERE'LL BE MANY MEANS
OF GETTING FOOD, BUT THE OTHER
PART WHERE CAL AIM COMES IN AND
IS FOR ME, I THINK THAT NEEDS TO
GET DONE FIRST. WE HAVE A HABIT
OF DOING THIS WHERE WE PILE ON,
AND THEN NOTHING GETS DONE IN
THE TIME THAT IT WAS SUPPOSED TO
GET DONE. BUT CAL AIM IS GETTING
DONE, SO IT'S ALREADY DONE. BUT
RIGHT. BUT NOW IS AS THE
OPPOSITION WITNESS, I'M NOT
GOING TO ARGUE IT. THE
OPPOSITION WITNESSES IN MY
CLOTHES. YEAH THE OPPOSITION
WITNESSES, KIND OF MADE IT CLEAR
THAT, SOME PLACES THAT MIGHT BE
GETTING DONE, BUT SOME PLACES IT
IS, IS NOT GOING TO GET DONE ON
TIME. WE WANT THAT TO GET DONE
ON TIME. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
SENATOR SKINNER, THANK YOU.
CHAIR, I WANT TO APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD. IT'S, ONE OF THESE I
WISH WE DIDN'T HAVE TO, BE
CONSIDERING SOMETHING IN
STATUTE, WE HAVE HAD VERY GOOD
EVIDENCE THAT ENROLLING OUR
FOLKS, WHETHER THEY'RE IN COUNTY
JAIL OR STATE PRISON, ENROLLING
THEM IN BENEFITS THEY ARE
QUALIFIED FOR, SUCH AS MEDI-CAL,
CALFRESH AND OTHERS GETTING THEM
THEIR ID, GIVING THEM ALL THOSE
THINGS FOR THEM TO ONCE THEY ARE
RELEASED, BE SUCCESSFUL. THAT
THAT THOSE ARE SOME OF THE MOST
SIMPLE THINGS THAT WE CAN DO TO
ENSURE OR GREATLY REDUCE
RECIDIVISM. WHEN YOU ARE SENT
OUT, FOR EXAMPLE, FROM STATE
PRISON WITH 200 BUCKS IN A PAPER
BAG AND YOU HAVE TO DEAL WITH
ALL OF THAT YOURSELF, YOU DON'T
EVEN HAVE HOUSING, YOU KNOW,
MOST OF US WOULD FALTER. SO I
WOULD LOVE TO, AND WE HAVE NOT
TRIED. WE HAVE BEEN, WORKING TO
PUT THESE KINDS OF THINGS IN
PLACE IN ALL OF OUR COUNTIES AND
THROUGHOUT OUR CDCR SYSTEM FOR
YEARS. AND, YOU KNOW, I WOULD
LOVE TO SEE IT AS A
COMPREHENSIVE THAT ALL OF THOSE
THINGS BE DONE AT ONCE, BUT, YOU
KNOW, SOMETIMES WE HAVE TO DO
LITTLE BY LITTLE. BUT THIS IS
VERY IMPORTANT. AND I MOVE THE
BILL. THANK YOU. I DO JUST WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT THAT, YOU KNOW, WE
OFTEN TALK ABOUT IN PUBLIC
SAFETY ABOUT, OBVIOUSLY
PUNISHING THE PERPETRATOR AND
PROTECTING THE VICTIM FIRST AND
FOREMOST. AND I THINK THAT THIS
COMMITTEE IS VERY MUCH DEDICATED
TO THAT. BUT I DO NOT OFTEN SEE
A LOT OF EFFORT IN THE REENTRY
SPACE. SO I APPRECIATE THIS
BILL. I DO JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT TO ALL OF THOSE THAT
ARE CONCERNED WITH THIS, ALSO,
AS CHAIR OF SUB FIVE, WE SEE A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF FUNDING TO
THE PUBLIC SAFETY AS A WHOLE,
WHETHER WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
COUNTY LEVEL, WE'RE WHETHER
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT JAIL, CDCR,
PUBLIC SAFETY AS A WHOLE, AS AN
INSTITUTION. AND, REENTRY IS A
BIG PART OF THAT THAT HAS BEEN
MISSING AND HAS NOT BEEN
INVESTED IN DEEPLY. WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT FOOD. FOOD. DO WE
WANT MORE AND MORE PEOPLE TO
STRUGGLE? PEOPLE WHO HAVE TO
DEAL WITH THE REENTRY PROCESS
ALREADY STRUGGLE IN REGARDS TO
GETTING A JOB IN REGARDS TO
GETTING HOUSING, THEY CANNOT
EVEN RENT IN SOME PLACES BECAUSE
OF BACKGROUND CHECKS. THEY
CANNOT EVEN GET A JOB BECAUSE OF
BACKGROUND CHECKS. AND THEY DID
THEIR TIME, AND SOMETIMES THEIR
CRIMES ALSO VARY. AND YET, WE
ARE NOT TRYING TO ISOLATE OR
SECLUDE THEM OR MAKE THEM
STRUGGLE ANY FURTHER THAN THEY
NEED TO ON BASIC NEEDS. AND SO I
DO APPRECIATE THIS. I HEAR THE
CONCERNS ABOUT CAL AIM AND
PROGRAMS AND TECHNOLOGY AND
IMPLEMENTATION, AND HONESTLY,
THOSE EXCUSES ARE NOT GOOD
ENOUGH TO SAY, NO, WE CAN'T DO
THIS. SO, SENATOR, I WOULD LOVE
FOR YOU TO CLOSE AND THEN CALL
FOR A VOTE. SURE THANK YOU. I
APPRECIATE THAT, CHAIR. YEAH, I
JUST WE'RE STARTING FROM THE
POSITION THAT CALIFORNIA IS ONE
OF THE HISTORICALLY ONE OF THE
LOWEST STATES TO HAVE PEOPLE WHO
ARE ELIGIBLE FOR CALFRESH SIGNED
UP. AND AGAIN, THAT'S FEDERAL
MONEY. THAT'S SOMETHING WE WERE
TRYING TO ADDRESS ACROSS THE
BOARD. AND THIS IS AN EASY WAY
TO START. AND I THINK YOU'RE
RIGHT TO HIGHLIGHT REENTRY. A
LOT OF MY WORK HAS BEEN FOCUSED
ON THAT, WHETHER IT'S THE PRISON
PHONE CALLS OR THE CANTEEN. WE
KEEP THOSE FAMILY RELATIONSHIPS
WICKS. WE DON'T EXHAUST
FAMILIES, WEALTH IN TRYING TO
HELP THEIR LOVED ONES
INCARCERATED AND THIS IS
BASICALLY SAYING I UNDERSTAND
THE CONCERN. BUT EVERY DAY WE
WAIT, EVERY PERSON WHO'S
RELEASED WITHOUT THIS IS SOMEONE
WHO'S IN DANGER OF FALLING INTO
HOMELESSNESS OR, OR REOFFENDING.
AND I THINK IT'S A COMMON SENSE
MEASURE WE'LL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH. WITH THE FOLKS AND I KNOW
THE CALIFORNIA WELFARE DIRECTOR
ASSOCIATION, WORK HARD. I KNOW
THEY'RE WORKING HARD ON CALAIM.
I KNOW MAJORITY OF COUNTIES HAVE
DONE, KELLY MORETTI, BUT I KNOW
SOME ARE STILL WORKING ON IT,
AND I DO WANT TO BE SENSITIVE TO
THAT, BUT THIS IS NOT AN OVERLY
COMPLICATED FORM. IT'S NOT AN
OVERLY COMPLICATED WAIVER. I'VE
BEEN TOLD. IT'S REALLY A FEW
QUESTIONS, AND, YOU KNOW, WE'LL
CONTINUE TALKING ABOUT THE
PROCESS BECAUSE WE WANT IT TO
WORK. BUT THANK YOU.
RESPECTFULLY ASKED FOR AN I
VOTE. WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR SKINNER. CAN WE CALL A
ROLL CALL VOTE, PLEASE. SB 1254,
THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. WAHAB A COBB.
AYE. SATO SATO. NO. BRADFORD.
SKINNER. A SKINNER. AYE. WIENER
THAT BILLS ON CALL. THANK YOU,
SENATOR, NEXT WE HAVE SENATOR
ASHBY WITH SB 970. I JUST ALSO
WANT TO SAY THAT I HAVE TO
PRESENT A BILL. SO I'M GOING TO
TURN IT OVER TO OUR VICE CHAIR,
SENATOR SATO, THANK YOU, SENATOR
ASHBY. THANK YOU. GREAT. I'M
HERE TO PRESENT SB 970, WHICH
ESTABLISHES A LEGAL FRAMEWORK
FOR REGULATING ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE. VOICE IMAGE, VIDEO
CLONING TECHNOLOGY. THE RISE OF
AI PRESENTS LOTS OF
OPPORTUNITIES AS WE ALL KNOW,
AND IS A POWERFUL TOOL. LOTS OF
MAJOR ADVANCES IN OUR TECHNOLOGY
WORLD AROUND AI. HOWEVER, THE
LACK OF A COMPREHENSIVE LEGAL
FRAMEWORK FOR ADDRESSING THE
CHALLENGES POSED BY AI IS
TROUBLING. LEAVING INDIVIDUALS
VULNERABLE FOR VARIOUS FORMS OF
EXPLOITATION, INCLUDING IDENTITY
THEFT, SCAMS AND MISINFORMATION,
ESPECIALLY WITH DEEP FAKES ON
THE RISE, ALTERED VIDEOS AND
IMAGES CREATE DOUBT AND
UNCERTAINTY AROUND CURRENT
EVENTS AND UNDERMINE THE PUBLIC
TRUST IN DIGITAL MEDIA. EFFORTS
TO REGULATE AI TECHNOLOGY SHOULD
FOCUS ON ENHANCING PUBLIC
AWARENESS ABOUT WHAT IS AND IS
NOT A DEEPFAKE. EMPOWERING
INDIVIDUALS TO IDENTIFY AND
MITIGATE POTENTIAL THREATS OR
MISINFORMATION. SO, VERY SIMPLY,
SB 970 ESTABLISHES A PENAL CODE
VIOLATION FOR THE MISUSE OF AI
VOICE OR VIDEO CLONING
TECHNOLOGY. IT GRANTS LEGAL
RECOURSE FOR VICTIMS HARMED BY
MISUSE OF AI. IT PREVENTS AI
GENERATED EVIDENCE TAMPERING IN
A COURTROOM SETTING AND CREATES
MANDATORY CONSUMER WARNINGS ON
AI CLONING SOFTWARE. THE BILL
PROVIDES A BALANCED LEGISLATIVE
FRAMEWORK THAT WEIGHS BOTH
INNOVATION AND INDIVIDUAL
PRIVACY TO PREVENT ABUSE AND
DISINFORMATION. THERE IS NO
OPPOSITION AI NORMALLY HAVE WITH
ME AN EXPERT WITNESS, HE HAD A
FAMILY EMERGENCY. HE SO COULDN'T
BE HERE TODAY. BUT WORTH NOTING
THAT HE IS ACTUALLY FROM THE AI
INDUSTRY IN LOS ANGELES, WHERE
HE WORKS IN TELEVISION AND MEDIA
PRODUCTION AND HE HELPED PUT
THIS FRAMEWORK TOGETHER AFTER
SEEING MANY OF THE FLAWS IN AI
TECHNOLOGY AND HOW IT WAS BEING
USED AND ABUSED. AND SO I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR ASHBY, AND THANK YOU FOR
EXPLAINING THAT LAST PART. DO WE
HAVE ANY OTHER OPPOSITION? I
MEAN, WITNESSES THAT ARE IN
FAVOR OF IT THAT WANT TO SPEAK,
AS A PRIMARY WITNESS? GOOD
MORNING, MR. CHAIRMAN. SENATOR
ASHBY, THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD. TOM SHEEHY,
REPRESENTING, PROTECTION OF THE
EDUCATIONAL RIGHTS OF KIDS,
ADVOCACY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE. THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE
ANYBODY WHO WISHES TO BE A
PRIMARY WITNESS IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS MEASURE, IF NOT ANY METOOS
FOR OPPOSITION OR IN FAVOR OF
THE BILL? I DON'T SEE ANYBODY
COMING UP TO THE MIC. SO WE'RE
GOING TO BRING IT BACK TO THE
DAIS. GO AHEAD, SENATOR SKINNER.
I MOVE THE BILL, SENATOR, WE HAD
A LIVELY DISCUSSION EARLIER ON
THIS QUESTION OF AI AND DEEP
FAKES AND ABOUT JUST THE GENERAL
CIRCUMSTANCE THAT WE AS
LEGISLATORS ARE FACING, WHERE
TECHNOLOGY VÆ. AND THIS IS NOT
JUST THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS.
IT'S BEEN ACTUALLY FOR 20 YEARS
NOW WHERE TECHNOLOGY IS MOVING
SO FAST THAT IT IT IS VERY
DIFFICULT FOR US TO GRAB TO GET
HOLD OF IT AND REALLY DO OUR JOB
TO PROTECT CONSUMERS. SO I
SUPPORT YOUR BILL, AND I THINK
THIS IS ANOTHER ONE OF OUR
LEGITIMATE EFFORTS TO PROTECT
OUR CONSUMERS. WITH THAT, I MOVE
IT. THANK YOU, SENATOR ASHBY.
YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU. I JUST
SAY TO, YOU KNOW, THIS BOARD,
FIRST OF ALL, I WANT TO THANK
YOUR STAFF. THEY'RE ALWAYS
REALLY GREAT WHEN WE BRING BILLS
THROUGH AT HELPING US SMOOTH OUT
THE EDGES. SO I APPRECIATE THAT.
BUT I ALSO YOU KNOW, THANK YOU,
SENATOR SKINNER, FOR YOUR WORK
IN THIS SPACE. WHAT I LIKE ABOUT
THIS BILL IS THAT IT? IT'S THE
BASICS. IT GIVES US THE
FRAMEWORK TO DO SOME OF THE
OTHER THINGS THAT FOLKS ARE
SEEKING TO DO TO PROTECT THIS
SPACE. I URGE, AND I VOTE, AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME AND THANK YOU. WE DO HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR SKINNER. GO
AHEAD AND CALL. ROLL SB 970. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. WAHAB SATO I
SATO I BRADFORD SKINNER I
SKINNER I WIENER. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. THAT BILL WILL REMAIN ON
CALL. SENATOR DURAZZO SOUNDS
LIKE YOU ARE NEXT. SENATOR OSO
WILL BE PRESENTING SB 1132.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND
COLLEAGUES, MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, SB 1132 CLARIFIES THE
AUTHORITY OF COUNTY HEALTH
OFFICERS TO ENTER AND INSPECT
PRIVATE DETENTION FACILITIES
OPERATING IN OUR STATE. EXISTING
LAW DOES NOT EXPLICITLY COVER
PRIVATE DETENTION FACILITIES,
INCLUDING CIVIL DETENTION
FACILITY USED TO DETAIN
IMMIGRANTS. TODAY, THERE ARE SIX
PRIVATE FACILITIES OPERATING IN
OUR STATE THAT CAN HOLD AS MANY
AS 7000 INDIVIDUALS AT A GIVEN
TIME. THESE FACILITIES ARE IN A
GRAY AREA UNDER OUR HEALTH AND
SAFETY CODES. WHILE PUBLIC
HEALTH OVERSIGHT LAWS EMPOWER
INSPECTIONS OF, QUOTE, PUBLICLY
OPERATED DETENTION FACILITIES
AND ALL PRIVATE WORKFORCE WORK
FURLOUGH FACILITIES, THEY DO NOT
EXPLICITLY COVER PRIVATE
DETENTION FACILITIES. THESE ARE
FACILITIES OPERATED FOR PROFIT
BY FOR PROFIT COMPANIES, AND
OFTEN FAIL TO MEET MINIMUM
STANDARDS OF HEALTH, SAFETY AND
SANITATION. IMPROVING
ACCOUNTABILITY AND OVERSIGHT IS
ESSENTIAL. SB 1132 PROVIDES
EXPLICIT AUTHORIZATION FOR
COUNTY HEALTH OFFICIALS TO BE
ABLE TO INSPECT THESE FACILITIES
WHENEVER NECESSARY, WITH ME, I
HAVE ANDREA AMAVIZCA, GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS MANAGER FOR THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER, TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT, AND
TO HELP ANSWER QUESTIONS WILL BE
JACKIE GONZALEZ OF THE IMMIGRANT
DEFENSE ADVOCATES. GREAT. YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES. IF YOU COULD
STICK TO THAT, I'D APPRECIATE
IT. THANK YOU. OKAY. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, MR. CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS ANDREA
AMAVIZCA, AND I'M THE GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS MANAGER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER. THANK YOU TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR HEARING MY
TESTIMONY TODAY. AND THANK YOU
TO SENATOR DURAZO FOR
INTRODUCING THIS IMPORTANT PIECE
OF LEGISLATION. THIS BILL
CONCERNS PUBLIC HEALTH OVERSIGHT
AND ACCOUNTABILITY OF PRIVATE,
FOR PROFIT DETENTION FACILITIES
THAT OPERATE IN OUR STATE. WHILE
CALIFORNIA NO LONGER HAS PRIVATE
JAILS OR PRISONS, THERE ARE SIX
PRIVATE DETENTION FACILITIES IN
OUR STATE USED FOR THE CIVIL
DETENTION OF IMMIGRANTS. THESE
FOR PROFIT FACILITIES HAVE A
HORRIFIC TRACK RECORD IN OUR
STATE. WHEN IT COMES TO HEALTH,
SAFETY AND HUMAN RIGHTS. AS A
SENATOR, SHARED DETENTION
FACILITIES CAN POSE A PUBLIC
HEALTH RISK TO INDIVIDUALS HELD
INSIDE, INDIVIDUALS WHO WORK
INSIDE, AND FAMILIES WHO VISIT
OR LIVE NEAR THESE FACILITIES.
CALIFORNIA WITNESSED THE FAILURE
OF THESE FACILITIES TO PROPERLY
AND HUMANELY RESPOND TO PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCIES. WHEN IN
2020, THE OTAY MESA DETENTION
FACILITY IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY
BECAME THE SITE OF WHAT WAS THEN
THE LARGEST OUTBREAK OF COVID 19
IN ANY DETENTION FACILITY, THE
OUTBREAK SPREAD TO MORE THAN 200
PEOPLE, INCLUDING INDIVIDUALS
DETAINED AND WORKING AT THE
FACILITY, AND TRAGICALLY, ONE
MAN DETAINED LOST HIS LIFE DUE
TO COVID DURING THIS OUTBREAK.
THIS IS REFLECTIVE OF A PATTERN
OF PRIVATE OPERATORS BELIEVING
THEY ARE ABOVE THE LAW, WHILE
ACTING NEGLIGENTLY WITH RESPECT
TO THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
PEOPLE IN THESE FACILITIES AND
THE COMMUNITIES THEY ARE LOCATED
IN. MORE OVER INVESTIGATIONS BY
CAL OSHA HAVE FOUND WILLFUL AND
SERIOUS HEALTH VIOLATIONS IN
PRIVATE DETENTION FACILITIES. AS
A 2021 REPORT BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE FOUND THAT
THE ADELANTO DETENTION FACILITY
IN SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY HAD
USED A CHEMICAL AGENT KNOWN AS
HDC NEUTRAL TO SANITIZE SURFACES
WHICH MANY INDIVIDUALS DETAINED
AT THIS FACILITY REPORTED WAS SO
TOXIC THAT THEY EXPERIENCED
HEADACHES, NAUSEA, NOSEBLEEDS,
FAINTING, EYE IRRITATION, SKIN
IRRITATION, AND BREATHING ISSUES
. THESE ARE JUST A FEW OF THE
MANY EXAMPLES OF PUBLIC HEALTH
VIOLATIONS THAT OCCUR IN THESE
FACILITIES, AND PART OF THE
URGENT NEED FOR A PUBLIC HEALTH
SOLUTION TO THIS PROBLEM.
ALTHOUGH THE ENFORCEMENT OF
IMMIGRATION LAWS IS A FEDERAL
ISSUE, THE OPERATION OF
IMMIGRANT DETENTION FACILITIES.
THAT'S. YOU HAD THE TWO MINUTES.
THANK YOU. RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE. NEXT SPEAKER UP,
PLEASE. NO OKAY. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. IS THERE ANYBODY WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS MEASURE? YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. OKAY SORRY, MR. CHAIR.
RYAN SHERMAN WITH THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. SO YOUR. ME TOO.
YES, SIR. NOT AN OPPOSITION
WITNESS THAT WANTED TO SPEAK IN
FAVOR OF THE BILL. I'D BE HAPPY
TO GIVE ANY TIME. NO, IT'S TOO
LATE. OKAY, WITH THAT, WE'LL
TAKE METOOS FOR OPPOSITION AND
SUPPORT. JOSHUA STICKNEY WITH
THE ELLA BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS AND SUPPORT. ISABELLA
ARGUETA WITH THE HEALTH OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. ALICE MICHAEL, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION, IN
SUPPORT Dð COONEY WITH THE ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION AND INITIATE
JUSTICE AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
LAWRENCE COX, ON BEHALF OF ALL
OF US, ARE NOT IN SUPPORT.
JOANNA WILLIAMS WITH LSPC IN
SUPPORT. DEBORAH ANTHONY
MURILLO, LSPC. AND ALSO NONE
SUPPORT ALYSSA MORE. ALL OF US
ARE NONE IN SUPPORT. GREAT.
THANK YOU ALL FOR. YEP, SORRY.
JACKIE GONZALEZ, POLICY DIRECTOR
, IMMIGRANT DEFENSE ADVOCATES IN
SUPPORT. ALSO HERE PROVIDING
SUPPORT FROM THE LAWYERS
COMMITTEE FOR CIVIL RIGHTS OF
THE SF BAY AREA, INLAND
COALITION FOR IMMIGRANT JUSTICE
NGUYEN VECINO FRIENDS, COMMITTEE
ON LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA,
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR WOMEN
PRISONERS, HUMAN IMPACT
PARTNERS, INDIVISIBLE
CALIFORNIA, LA COSECHA COUNCIL,
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATIVE FOR
IMMIGRANT JUSTICE, ASIAN
AMERICANS, ADVANCING JUSTICE,
SOCAL SECURE JUSTICE, AND NEXT
GEN CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY. WE'RE GOING
TO BRING IT BACK TO THE DÍAS.
ANY QUESTIONS? I MOVE THE BILL.
WE HAVE A MOTION TO MOVE THE
BILL. MR. ROGER, WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE? THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
AND I HOPE YOU ALL SUPPORT THE
BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
SECRETARY. YOU CAN CALL THE ROLL
SB 1132. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO THE FLOOR. WAHAB
SEYARTO SEYARTO BRADFORD.
SKINNER. SKINNER. AYE. WIENER.
AYE. WIENER AYE. ALL RIGHT. THAT
BILL REMAIN ON CALL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE COULD
GET A CALL OUT FOR MORE. AUTHOR.
OH, WE GOT MORE AUTHORS. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. OKAY, MISS
MENJIVAR, SB 1057, YOU'RE READY
WHENEVER YOU ARE. THIS IS
AWKWARD. WE ARE READY WHENEVER
YOU ARE. THAT'S ALL RIGHT. SAY
THANK YOU, MR. VICE CHAIR. GOOD
MORNING EVERYONE. I WILL BE
TAKING THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
I WANT TO THANK, THE CHAIR WHO
WAS IN HERE, BUT ALSO THE
COMMITTEE TEAM. WE'RE WORKING
WITH MY TEAM ON CLARIFYING THE
INTENT OF THIS BILL, AND LET ME
SILENCE MY PHONE HERE. SB 1056
1057 IS LOOKING TO CONTINUE THE
GREAT STRIDES WE'VE MADE IN
USHERING A NEW HEALTH BASED
APPROACH, MOVING FROM YOUTH
INCARCERATION, INCARCERATE TO
YOUTH DEVELOPMENT. BUT THERE
REMAINS STILL MORE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR IMPROVEMENT. ONE URGENT
OPPORTUNITY IS RECTIFYING THE
FLAWED IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
JUVENILE COORDINATING COUNCILS,
WHICH MOVING FORWARD, I'LL JUST
CALL JJK THE LACK OF COMMUNITY
REPRESENTATION ON COUNTIES. JJK
HAS CAUSED US TO FALL SHORT OF
THE INTENDED GOAL. WHEN THESE
COUNCILS WERE CREATED, SB 1056
1057 SEEKS TO REMEDY THIS
PROBLEM BY CREATING A MORE
EQUITABLE JJK COMPOSITION IN THE
FOLLOWING WAY. WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE 50% OF
COMMUNITY REPRESENTATION ON THIS
COUNCIL. WE WANT TO ADD A
COMMUNITY REPRESENTATIVE AS A
CO-CHAIR, AND WITH THE
AMENDMENTS WE TOOK, WE CLARIFIED
THAT THE OTHER CO-CHAIR WILL BE
THE CHIEF PROBATION OFFICER, AND
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
COLLECTING EVIDENCE TO SUPPORT
THE PROGRAMS AND STRATEGIES
FUNDED BY THE JUSTICE, THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE CRIME
PREVENTION ACT, INCLUDING
FEEDBACK FROM YOUTH
PARTICIPANTS, THE EXPERTISE OF
THOSE WHO ARE MOST IMPACTED BY
THE SYSTEM, AND THOSE WORKING
ALONGSIDE THEM WITH THE TRAUMA
INFORMED, HEALING FOCUSED LENS
ON INVALUABLE TO IMPLEMENTING
THE JCPOA, SB 1057 WOULD REQUIRE
COUNTIES TO BRING THOSE EXPERTS
TO THE TABLE. HOWEVER IT IS NOT
ENOUGH SIMPLY TO HAVE A SEAT AT
THE TABLE. IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
FOR THEM TO BE PART OF THE
LEADERSHIP, WHICH IS WHY SB 1057
IS ASKING FOR A COMMUNITY
REPRESENTATIVE TO BE A CO-CHAIR
TO ENSURE THAT EVERYONE FEELS
SAFE IN THIS PROCESS. I WANT TO
ASSURE YOU ALL THAT THIS DOES
NOT DEFUND PROBATION, NOR DOES
IT REQUIRE THAT PROBATION OR
OTHER COUNTY AGENCIES ARE LEFT
BEHIND. SB 1057 SIMPLY
SUPPLEMENTS THE CURRENT EFFORTS
BY ADDING COMMUNITY VOICE TO THE
DECISION MAKING PROCESS.
EVERYTHING IN STATUTE ALREADY
DECLARES THAT THESE COUNCILS
HAVE TO EXIST. EVERYTHING IN
STATUE. STATUE ALREADY DECLARES
THAT THEY HAVE TO PROVIDE A
REPORT TO BC AND THE LEGISLATURE
ON HOW THEY'RE USING THE FUNDING
. THEY AND IN CURRENT STATUTE
RIGHT NOW, IT STATES THAT SHOULD
THEY NOT DO THAT, THEY COULD BE
AT RISK OF LOSING FUNDING. WE'RE
NOT CHANGING ANYTHING IN STATUTE
OUTSIDE OF ADDING 50. COMMUNITY
REPRESENTATIVES AND A CO-CHAIR
WITH SOME ADDITIONAL DATA
POINTS. WE WANT TO HAVE
COLLECTED. SO TO THAT EFFECT,
MISTER VICE CHAIR, I WOULD LIKE
TO NOW TURN IT OVER TO TWO OF MY
WITNESSES THAT ARE HERE TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF
MY BILL. I'D LIKE TO. I'D LIKE
TO WELCOME UP, JOHN VASQUEZ,
POLICY MANAGER WITH THE
COMMUNITIES UNITED FOR
RESTORATIVE YOUTH JUSTICE.
FIRST, MISTER VASQUEZ, THANK YOU
FOR COMING THIS MORNING. YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
JOHN VASQUEZ. I'M THE POLICY
MANAGER WITH COMMUNITIES UNITED
FOR RESTORATIVE YOUTH JUSTICE,
AN ORGANIZATION THAT SERVES
SYSTEM IMPACTED YOUTH. I MYSELF
SPENT SEVERAL YEARS IN THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM. SB
1057, THE YOUTH JUSTICE, EQUITY
AND REPRESENTATION ACT IS A
COMMON SENSE APPROACH TO
ENSURING THAT SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTS WITH LIVED EXPERIENCE,
AS WELL AS REPRESENTATIVES FROM
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
WHO PROVIDE DIRECT SERVICES TO
YOUTH, ARE PART OF THE DECISION
MAKING PROCESS AND CREATING AND
UPDATING COUNTY SPECIFIC
JUVENILE JUSTICE PLANS. WE
BELIEVE THAT THOSE CLOSEST TO
THE PROBLEM ARE CLOSEST TO THE
SOLUTION. THEREFORE, IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT SYSTEM IMPACTED
STAKEHOLDERS HAVE A VOICE TO
INFLUENCE POLICIES THAT DIRECTLY
AFFECT THE SAFETY AND HEALTH OF
THEIR COMMUNITIES, THEIR
FAMILIES, AND THEIR YOUTH. AS
COMMUNITY STAKEHOLDERS, WE ALL
WANT AT PROMISE YOUTH TO HEAL,
GROW AND THRIVE. UNFORTUNATELY,
CURRENT JUVENILE JUSTICE
COORDINATING COUNCILS LACK THESE
CRITICAL VOICES IN A MEANINGFUL
WAY. MOREOVER, DUE TO THE LARGE
DIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA'S 58
COUNTIES, A ONE SIZE FITS ALL
APPROACH DOES NOT WORK. THIS
BILL GIVES EACH COUNTY MORE
FLEXIBILITY AND CONTROL OVER THE
SIZE OF THEIR COUNCILS, WITH
MORE POPULATED COUNTIES LIKELY
HAVING LARGER COUNCILS, WHILE
SMALLER RURAL COUNTIES LIKELY
HAVING SMALLER COUNCILS.
ULTIMATELY, THIS BILL ALLOWS
EACH COUNTY TO DECIDE WHAT WORKS
BEST FOR THEM. I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THANK
YOU FOR STICKING TO THE TIME
LIMIT, NEXT SPEAKER, PRIMARY
WITNESS IN FAVOR OF THE. YES,
I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE ADI SHAKUR
WITH THE CHILDREN'S DEFENSE
FUND. SHAKUR, WELCOME. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS
SHAKUR. I'M A SENIOR POLICY
ASSOCIATE AT THE CHILDREN'S
DEFENSE FUND CALIFORNIA, AND WE
ARE BASED IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
FOR SEVERAL YEARS, CHILDREN'S
DEFENSE FUND, ALONG WITH OUR
COALITION PARTNERS, HAVE BEEN
HIGHLIGHTING HOW THE
ADMINISTRATION OF JJDPA GRANT IN
LA COUNTY HAS HISTORICALLY BEEN
ILL SPENT, UNDERUTILIZED, AND
ILL EVALUATED, AND WE HAVE HAD
SOME SUCCESS REMEDYING THESE
SHORTCOMINGS AND SEEING
FIRSTHAND HOW ADDING COMMUNITY
VOICE TO OUR JJC HAS LED TO A
BETTER FUNCTIONING SYSTEM. IN
APRIL 2016, LA COUNTY WAS
WOEFULLY OUT OF COMPLIANCE WITH
THE MINIMUM REQUIREMENTS UNDER
THE WELFARE AND INSTITUTIONS
CODE FOR WHO SITS ON THEIR JJC.
IN RESPONSE TO ADVOCATE
PRESSURE, LA COUNTY ADDED TEN
COMMUNITY REPRESENTATIVE SEATS
TO THEIR JJC AND WE NOW HAVE A
27 MEMBER JJC. SINCE THE
ADDITION OF THE COMMUNITY
REPRESENTATIVES, THE JJC HAS
DONE A MUCH BETTER JOB OF
ENGAGING COMMUNITY CENTERING
YOUTH VOICE AND MOVING FORWARD.
THE MISSION OF THE JJC. A GRANT
ONE OF THE FIRST THINGS THAT THE
NEWLY COMPOSED JJC DID WAS
REEVALUATE THE ANNUAL SPENDING
PLAN, WHICH HAD SAT UNTOUCHED
SINCE 2001. AS A RESULT OF THE
NEW PLAN, $12.5 MILLION WERE
TAKEN FROM THE JJC GRANT AND
INVESTED IN A PRIVATE PUBLIC
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE
PROBATION DEPARTMENT,
FOUNDATIONS AND YOUTH SERVING
ORGANIZATIONS. THE PROGRAM IS
CALLED READY TO RISE, AND IT
SERVES YOUTH IN MANY PARTS OF
THE COUNTY. WITH A DEARTH OF
YOUTH SERVICES. IN THE FIRST
THREE YEARS, IT SERVED 25,594
YOUNG PEOPLE WITH MENTORSHIP,
LEADERSHIP DEVELOPMENT, ACADEMIC
AND CAREER SUPPORT, AND ARTS
EDUCATION. WHILE WE ARE PROUD OF
THIS PROGRESS, WE KNOW THAT
THERE ARE STILL IMPEDIMENTS TO
REALIZING THE FULL VISION OF THE
JJC. DESPITE THE EXPANSION OF
THE JJC MEMBERSHIP, THERE IS
STILL NOT AN ADEQUATE BALANCE OF
COMMUNITY STAKEHOLDERS ON OUR
JJC PROBATION AND COUNTY OFFICES
HAVE OUTSIZED INFLUENCE IN JJC
DECISIONS AT THE EXPENSE OF
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM COMMUNITY
REPRESENTATIVES WITH THE MOST
KNOWLEDGE OF WHAT YOUNG PEOPLE
GO THROUGH. THEREFORE I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS IMPORTANT
BILL TODAY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, AT THIS TIME, WE'LL
TAKE, WITNESSES, OUR PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU.
CHAIR, COMMITTEE AND STAFF, RYAN
MOONEY WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES HERE IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO SB
1057, FIRST AND FOREMOST,
COUNTIES VALUE THE COMMUNITY
PARTNERSHIPS, THE WORK AND TRUST
WITH OUR CBOS AND THE JUSTICE
IMPACTED YOUTH POPULATION AND
REALIZED THAT REPRESENTATION
DOES MATTER. HOWEVER, CURRENT
LAW ENSURES THIS BY PROVIDING
THAT A JUVENILE JUSTICE
COORDINATING COUNCIL INCLUDES AT
LARGE COMMUNITY REPRESENTATIVE,
A REPRESENTATIVE OF A COMMUNITY
BASED DRUG AND ALCOHOL PROGRAM,
AND GUARANTEES THAT THE COUNCIL
SHALL ALSO INCLUDE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM NONPROFIT,
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
THAT SAID, AS WITH PREVIOUS
ITERATIONS OF THIS BILL, WE
FUNDAMENTALLY OPPOSE THAT IN
COMBINATION, OPPOSE CHANGES THAT
IN COMBINATION LEAD TO A
DIMINISHED AUTHORITY OVER
MANDATED RESPONSIBILITIES. AND
AS CURRENTLY DRAFTED, COULD ALSO
LEAD TO WITHHOLDING OR
DISRUPTION OF JJC FUNDS, WHICH
ONLY HURTS THE YOUTH AND YOUNG
ADULTS THAT ARE IN COUNTY CARE.
I'D BE REMISS IF I DIDN'T NOTE
THAT THE JJC FUNDS WERE
ALLOCATED TO COUNTIES TO
ACCOMPANY SERVICES REALIGNED. IN
2011, THE JJC MOVED UNDER 2011
REALIGNMENT FISCAL STRUCTURE TO
ENSURE IT WOULD REMAIN A STABLE
AND FOUNDATIONAL FUNDING SOURCE
FOR COUNTIES AND THEN IN 2012,
PROPOSITION 30 FURTHER PROTECTED
THE FUNDING FOR ALL ACCOUNTS
UNDER 2011 REALIGNMENT AND
GUARANTEED THAT LOCAL AGENCIES
HAVE MAXIMUM FLEXIBILITY AND
CONTROL OVER THE DESIGN. THE
PROCESS FOR ALLOCATING JJC FUNDS
SHOULD REMAIN A COUNTY DECISION,
GIVEN THAT COUNTIES ARE HELD
FULLY ACCOUNTABLE FOR DELIVERY
OF PROGRAMS AND SERVICES, AS
WELL AS OUTCOMES ASSOCIATED WITH
JUSTICE, INVOLVED YOUTH, AND
ALSO ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF JJ'S
FINAL CLOSURE NOT EVEN ONE YEAR
AGO, WITH COUNTIES, NOW
OVERSEEING THE ENTIRE JUVENILE
JUSTICE CONTINUUM. AND WE'RE
REALISTIC ABOUT OUR CURRENT
BUDGET DEFICIT. HOWEVER, WE
WOULD ALWAYS ENCOURAGE A
COLLABORATIVE DISCUSSION ON
SEPARATE AND NEW INVESTMENTS TO
MAKE SURE YOU DON'T TOUCH OUR
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM IN THE
FIRST PLACE. LASTLY THANK THE
AUTHORS OFFICE FOR MEETING WITH
US AND APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU FOR
STICKING TO THE TWO MINUTES.
NEXT, WITNESS, PRIMARY WITNESS
IN OPPOSITION. YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. DANIEL SANCHEZ, ON
BEHALF OF THE CHIEF PROBATION
OFFICERS OF CALIFORNIA AND
OPPOSITION TO SB 1057. AND DO
ONE ALSO ACKNOWLEDGE OUR
CONVERSATIONS AND ONGOING
ENGAGEMENT WITH THE AUTHOR
AROUND THIS ISSUE. WE DO,
HOWEVER, THOUGH, HAVE TO
DISAGREE WITH THE ASSERTION THAT
THE CURRENT COMPOSITION OF THE
COUNCIL HAS LED TO FLAWED JCPOA
IMPLEMENTATION. TO THE CONTRARY,
THERE'S A LONG HISTORY IN TRACK
RECORD OF JCPA, WHICH HAS LED TO
HISTORIC DECLINES IN JUVENILE
DETENTION AND ARREST RATES OVER
THE LAST DECADE. THE EXISTING
JJC PROGRAM MEETS THE GOALS OF
TRANSPARENCY, COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT AND LOCALLY
RESPONSIVE PROGRAMS. THIS CAN BE
SEEN THROUGH THE PLANNING
PROCESS THAT INCLUDES COUNTY
PARTNERS, COMMUNITY MEMBERS THAT
COORDINATE PLANS, PUBLICLY POST
THOSE PLANS BY SENDING THEM TO
THE STATE, WHICH OUTLINE THE
STRATEGIES AND GOALS AROUND
LOCAL NEEDS. THESE COMMUNITY
PARTNERSHIPS EXIST AMONG COUNTY
DEPARTMENTS, AS WELL AS
COMMUNITY PARTNERS, TO PROVIDE
THINGS SUCH AS SCHOOL BASED
WELLNESS, SUBSTANCE USE SUPPORT,
MENTORING AND COUNSELING,
ENRICHMENT, CAREER DEVELOPMENT,
AND MANY EXAMPLES AS REFLECTED
IN THE PLAN. THIS BILL, HOWEVER,
MAKES SWEEPING CHANGES TO HOW
THOSE PLANS ARE DEVELOPED,
ESTABLISHES NEW MECHANISMS TO
WITHHOLD FUNDING TO COUNTIES,
WHICH ALSO I MUST NOTE, HAS AN
INTERPLAY WITH THE NEW
COMPOSITION REQUIREMENTS OF THE
COUNCIL AND RECAST AND REDIRECTS
COUNTY FUNDING THAT SUPPORTS
SERVICES LOCALLY. WE SERVE THE
ENTIRE JUVENILE JUSTICE
CONTINUUM, AND IT'S CRITICAL AND
VITAL THAT WE DO NOT DISRUPT THE
PREVENTION PART OF THAT
CONTINUUM, IN IN SOME OF THE
ISSUES IN THIS BILL, WE
CERTAINLY ARE CONCERNED WILL
UPEND THAT. PROBATION
CONTINUALLY ENGAGES IN
INNOVATION PROGRAMS AND
PARTNERSHIPS, AND WE BELIEVE THE
GOALS OF COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT
AND TRANSPARENCY ARE ALREADY
REFLECTED IN THE JJC FRAMEWORK
AND THE LONG HISTORY AND
OUTCOMES AROUND THIS BILL. SO
FOR THOSE REASONS, WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL TODAY, AND
CERTAINLY ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE IMPACTS OF THIS BILL ON THE
CRITICAL SERVICE DELIVERY OF
SERVICES TO YOUTH. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, NEXT UP, WE
WILL TAKE THE ME TOO'S FOR
PEOPLE THAT ARE IN OPPOSITION OR
SUPPORT OF THE BILL, PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME, THE
ORGANIZATION YOU REPRESENT, AND
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT IT OR YOU
OPPOSE IT. GOOD MORNING, MR.
CHAIR. MEMBERS. ELIZABETH
ESPINOSA HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE URBAN COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA
, A COALITION OF 14 OF THE MOST
POPULOUS COUNTIES IN THE STATE,
AS WELL AS THE COUNTY OF SANTA
BARBARA, IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. NICOLE WATERMAN, ON BEHALF OF
THE ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS, ALSO IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. NICOLE MORALES, ON
BEHALF OF CHILDREN NOW IN
SUPPORT. JOHN KENNEDY WITH THE
RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION. JOSHUA
STICKNEY, ON BEHALF OF THE ELLA
BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS IN
SUPPORT MATTHEW SEIBERLING ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
PROBATION OFFICERS UNION. ASK ME
LOCAL 685. IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. Dð COONEY ON BEHALF OF ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION AND INITIATE
JUSTICE AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING. ALBERTO TORRICO,
ON BEHALF OF THE STATE COALITION
, PROBATION ORGANIZATIONS,
OPPOSITION. LISMORE IN SUPPORT.
ALL OF US ARE NONE. LAWRENCE
COX, LSPC. ALL OF US ARE NONE.
STRONG SUPPORT. ALICE MICHAEL,
ON BEHALF OF CPA AND SUPPORT.
KRISTEN SCHLUSSEL, SACRAMENTO
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION,
IN RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU, DYLAN ELLIOTT, ON BEHALF OF
THE COUNTIES OF SAN LUIS OBISPO,
KERN, FRESNO AND MARIN.
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED. GILBERT,
ANTHONY MURILLO, LSPC, AND ALSO
NONE STRONGLY SUPPORT, LUCA
FAZIO ON BEHALF OF FRESH
LIFELINES FOR YOUTH AND STRONG
SUPPORT. COLIN FORD, ON BEHALF
OF ACCESS FOR REPRODUCTIVE
JUSTICE. ARTS FOR HEALING AND
JUSTICE NETWORK CALIFORNIANS
UNITED FOR RESPONSIBLE BUDGET.
COLLECTIVE FOR LIBERTY. LIBERATE
TREE LAWYERING. COURAGE.
CALIFORNIA. FREEDOM FOR YOUTH,
HAYWOOD BURNS INSTITUTE, AND
IMMIGRANT LEGAL RESOURCE CENTER
IN STRONG SUPPORT. LINA MALLET
WITH THE LOS ANGELES YOUTH
UPRISING COALITION. PROJECTS
MILPA COLLECTIVE. PACIFIC
JUVENILE DEFENDER CENTER,
SILICON VALLEY DEBUG STUDENTS
DESERVE UNCOMMON LAW,
UNDERGROUND GRIT, URBAN PEACE
INSTITUTE, WOMEN'S FREEDOM
FOUNDATION, CALIFORNIA, AND
YOUNG WOMEN'S FREEDOM CENTER IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK RYAN
SHERMAN WITH THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION. WE HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL,
ALTHOUGH WE DON'T HAVE OFFICIAL
OPPOSITION LETTER SUBMITTED JUST
YET. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. IF
THERE'S NOBODY ELSE WE'RE GOING
TO BRING BACK TO THE DAIS FOR
DISCUSSION OR A MOTION, I MOVE
THE BILL AND THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING FORWARD. THE AUTHOR
HAS BEEN THANKED. THE BILL HAS
BEEN MOVED. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE MISS MENGIBAR, ABSOLUTELY.
AND I, I WANT TO KNOW THAT THERE
WAS A STATE AUDIT IN 2020 THAT
STATED THAT 20% OF THE COUNTIES
DID NOT, IN FACT, HAVE A
COUNCIL, YOU HEARD FROM
REPRESENTATIVES FROM FRESNO
COUNTY WHO WERE IN FACT ALSO
FOUND IN 21 AND 22 TO HAVE BEEN
FOUND TO BE UNLAWFULLY HOLDING
MEETINGS ON JUVENILE JUSTICE
REFORM BEHIND CLOSED DOORS
AGAINST CURRENT STATUE. WE ARE
SEEING THAT DIFFERENT COUNTIES
ARE MAKING LIMITED REVISIONS TO
THEIR PLANS OVER THE PAST 20
YEARS, DESPITE THE FACT THAT
YOUTH INCARCERATION HAS
DECREASED. SO THE NEED FOR THIS
BILL IS THERE. WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THERE IS EQUITABLE
REPRESENTATION IN EACH COUNCIL.
WE ALSO HAVE HEARD SITUATIONS
WHERE COUNTIES ARE PREVENTING
YOUTH OR YOUNG ADULTS WHO ARE ON
PROBATION FROM BEING PART OF THE
COUNCIL. THE ABSOLUTE CONTRARY
TO WHAT THE PURPOSE OF THIS BILL
OF WHAT THIS BILL DOES. SO AGAIN
, THIS DOESN'T REMOVE THE
CURRENT MEMBERS ON THE COUNCIL,
RIGHT NOW. DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
CAN STILL PARTICIPATE ON THIS
COUNCIL PROBATION CAN STILL
PARTICIPATE ON THIS. COUNCIL
COUNTIES HAVE THE ABILITY TO PUT
PEOPLE ON THIS COUNCIL HOW THEY
SEE FIT. ALL THEY HAVE TO DO IS
THAT IF THEY CHOOSE 11 MEMBERS
TO BE ON THIS COUNCIL, THEN
ANOTHER 11 MEMBERS HAVE TO BE
FROM THE COMMUNITY. IF THEY
CHOOSE FIVE, THEN ANOTHER FIVE
HAVE TO BE FROM THE COMMUNITY.
WE'RE JUST ASKING TO MATCH THE
SAME AMOUNT OF NUMBERS THAT THE
COUNTY IS LOOKING TO PUT AS,
COMPARED TO COMMUNITY
REPRESENTATIVES. AND THEN LASTLY
, I'LL STATE I WANT TO READ
EXISTING LAW RIGHT NOW REGARDING
THE FUNDING OF HOW IT COMES DOWN
TO COUNTIES EXISTING LAW RIGHT
NOW PROVIDES THAT TO BE ELIGIBLE
FOR THE GRANT, EACH COUNTY IS
REQUIRED TO ESTABLISH A
MULTI-AGENCY JUVENILE JUSTICE
COORDINATING COUNCIL THAT
DEVELOPS AND IMPLEMENTS A
CONTINUUM OF COUNTY BASED
RESPONSES TO JUVENILE CRIME. SO
CURRENTLY, ALREADY THEY HAVE TO
PUT THIS COUNCIL TOGETHER TO BE
ELIGIBLE FOR THE GRANT FUNDING
THAT COMES DOWN FROM THE STATE.
WE'RE FURTHER PUSHING AND
REMINDING COUNTIES THAT THIS IN
FACT, IS STATUTE, AND MY LAW IS
EXPLICITLY PROVIDING THAT IN
ORDER FOR A COUNTY OR MY BILL IS
LOOKING THAT IN ORDER FOR A
COUNTY OR CITY TO BE ELIGIBLE
FOR FUNDING AND MUST ESTABLISH A
COORDINATED COUNCIL PRETTY
SIMILAR TO WHAT IS ALREADY IN
STATUTE. SO WITH THAT,
RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR AN I
VOTE. OKAY, THIS IS Dð PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS AS AMENDED. GO
AHEAD AND CALL ROLL. SB 1057.
MOTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED,
TO APPROPRIATIONS. WAHAB SATO
NO. SATO. NO BRADFORD. SKINNER.
SKINNER. AYE. WIENER WIENER. AYE
THANK YOU FOR THAT. WIENER WAS
ABSENT. OKAY, THAT MEASURE WILL
REMAIN ON CALL, AT THIS TIME,
WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD AND LIFT
THE CALL ON THE MEASURES SO THAT
SENATOR WIENER CAN ADD ON, AND
THEN WE WILL TAKE ON MR.
PORTANTINO'S BILL. SB 910. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
4 TO 0. WIENER Ã WIENER. I THAT
BILLS OUT FIVE ZERO SB 926.
WAHAB MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 3 TO 0. WIENER
Ã WIENER. I WELL THAT LEAVE IT
OPEN. THAT BILL IS. BRADFORD.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD. BRADFORD WAS
NOT. YEAH. THAT BILL WILL REMAIN
ON CALL. SB 935. MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
2 TO 0. WIENER WIENER I THAT
WILL STAY ON CALL. SB 1254
MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
2 TO 1. WIENER Ã WIENER I. THAT
BILL WILL REMAIN ON CALL. SB 970
MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
2 TO 0. WIENER WIENER I ON CALL
THAT BILL REMAIN ON CALL CONSENT
CALENDAR WIENER IS THAT SIX AND
767 AND OUR COMMITTEE VOTE TÍNH.
WAIT NÓ WIENER I TÍNH. YEAH I
CAN SO THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
OUT AND THAT WILL BE IT. SENATOR
PORTANTINO 000 I'M OUT. SB 1267.
ACTUALLY, MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
3 TO 0. WIENER. THAT'S A DOLLY
BILL. YEAH, I WIENER I AND THEN
1130, ITEM 16, ACTUALLY, SB 1144
SKINNER MOTION IS Dð PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
3 TO 0. WIENER WIENER I THAT
BILLS OUT. THAT BLOWS OUT. AND
THEN. 1132 HB. 11 1132 NUMBER
NINE OKAY, SORRY. HOLD ON. I
HAVE IT I HAVE HIM ON THAT. I
THINK YOU'RE ALREADY ON IT. I'M
ALREADY ON. OKAY. ALL RIGHT. WHY
DON'T WE. YEAH. WHY DON'T WE GO
BACK TO THE AUTHOR, TAKE UP THE
BILL WE HAVE THE AUTHOR FOR AND,
AND ALLOW THE PROCEEDINGS TO
BEGIN, AND WE'LL OPEN IT UP
LATER. AGAIN SENATOR PORTANTINO.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS, I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS OUTLINED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AND THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
MY STAFF. SB 1160 WITH EXTEND
THE INCREASED PUNISHMENT FOR
OPENLY CARRYING A HANDGUN TO
ALSO APPLY IF AN INDIVIDUAL IS
IN IMMEDIATE POSSESSION OF A
HANDGUN THAT IS NOT IN THE SAME
NAME AS THE LISTED WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AS THE
OWNER OF THE HANDGUN, SEVERAL
DECADES OF CASE LAW OF
DEMONSTRATED A HISTORY AND
SUPPORT OF DOCUMENTATION FOR
OWNING A FIREARM VIA MINISTERIAL
REGISTRATION SYSTEM. THE SYSTEM
WORKS IN DISTRICT OF COLUMBIA
VERSUS HELLER. IT WAS UPHELD AT
MINISTERIAL REGISTRATION SYSTEM
IN SEVERAL CASES AND IN AND
JUSTICE VERSUS TOWN OF CICERO
FURTHER FOUND REGISTRATION
MERELY REGULATING GUN POSSESSION
RATHER THAN PROHIBITING IT. SO
WE THINK THIS IS ON SOLID LEGAL
GROUNDS, SB 1160 WOULD APPLY A
SIMILAR SYSTEM TO HANDGUNS IN
CONDUCT BASED OFFENSES, WHERE AN
INDIVIDUAL IS FOUND TO BE
CARRYING A HANDGUN ILLEGALLY. SO
SB 1160 IS FURTHERMORE
CONSISTENT WITH CURRENT
LEGISLATION ENHANCING
REGISTRATION REQUIREMENTS AND
COMPLIANCE, AND IT WILL INCREASE
RESPONSE GUN OWNERSHIP. AGAIN,
WHEN YOU PURCHASE A GUN, IT'S
LISTED WITH THE DOJ. THIS GOES
AFTER THOSE PEOPLE WHO ARE
CARRYING THOSE HANDGUNS THAT ARE
NOT LISTED OR IN A DIFFERENT
NAME. WE THINK IT'S APPROPRIATE.
WE THINK IT WILL EXTEND,
RESPONSIBILITY TO RESPONSIBLE
GUN OWNERSHIP AND WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. AND THE INCOMPARABLE,
AMAZING IMAN IS HERE FOR ANY
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. IF WE HAVE
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS. DID YOU
WANT TO DID HE WANT TO SPEAK AS
A PRIMARY WITNESS OR IS HE JUST
HERE? THAT COULD BE QUITE
DANGEROUS, IF YOU'RE GOING TO
SPEAK AS A PRIMARY WITNESS, YOU
GOT TWO MINUTES. ALL RIGHT, THE
ANALYSIS WAS GREAT. ALEX
CORRECTLY POINTED OUT THAT THE
VAST MAJORITY OF HANDGUNS
LEGALLY OWNED IN THE STATE ARE,
IN FACT, REGISTERED. SO THIS IS
PART OF THE EFFORT TO GET MORE
GUNS INTO THE SYSTEM. WE DO NOT
WANT TO DISCOURAGE REGISTRATION
AT CERTAIN MEASURES OVER THE
ASSEMBLY, PURPORTED TO DO. BUT
WE'RE FIXED, THE SECOND THING
IS, IS THERE HAVE BEEN ONGOING
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE ABOUT AN ISSUE VERY
IMPORTANT TO THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
COMMUNITY AND ALSO THE GUN
PEOPLE, AND THAT'S INVOLVING
JOINT SPOUSAL REGISTRATION. I
HAVE DIRECTLY SPOKEN TO THE HEAD
PEOPLE THERE AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO THAT ISSUE BEING ADDRESSED.
FINALLY AS TO ALL THE QUESTION
ABOUT EXEMPTIONS AND HUNTERS AND
ALL THAT, WHEN WE DID THE
ORIGINAL BILL, WHICH SENATOR
THEN ASSEMBLYMAN PORTANTINO
CARRIED IN 2011, WE ADDED IN SO
MANY EXEMPTIONS FROM THE
PROHIBITION ON UNLOAD OPEN
HANDGUN CARRY THAT CERTAIN
MEMBERS OF YOUR CAUCUS SENATOR
SAID. IT'S LIKE A JOKE. SO
SAYING THE RIGHT GOT UP AND THEN
SAID, WELL, WHICH EXEMPTIONS DO
YOU WANT TO TAKE OUT OF THE
BILL? NOBODY ASKS FOR ANY
EXEMPTIONS TO BE TAKEN OUT. IT
DOESN'T AFFECT HUNTERS. THEY'RE
EXEMPT. PEOPLE WHO ALREADY CAN
CARRY LOADED, THEY CAN CARRY
UNLOADED OPENLY. THIS CARRY
COVERS A VERY, VERY NARROW
SITUATION BECAUSE THERE'S STILL
A QUESTION ABOUT WHAT LAWFUL
POSSESSION MEANS. AND I'M DONE.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. ANYBODY ELSE
WANT TO TESTIFY AS A PRIMARY
WITNESS IN SUPPORT? IF NOT,
WE'LL TAKE PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. AT THIS TIME,
THERE'S NO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. WE'LL TAKE ME TWOS
IN SUPPORT OR IN OPPOSITION.
JUST PLEASE COME UP TO THE MIC.
ANNOUNCE YOUR NAME, YOUR
ORGANIZATION, YOU REPRESENT, AND
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
THIS BILL. MR. CHAIR MEMBERS
RANDY PERRY WITH AARON REED AND
ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF PORK, WE
DID HAVE AN OPPOSE ON THE
ORIGINAL BILL, IT'S BEEN
SUBSTANTIALLY AMENDED. SO WE'RE
LOOKING AT IT NOW. LIKELY REMOVE
OUR OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. ON
IOAKIMIDIS WITH LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT. ANYBODY UP, MR.
CHAIRMAN? LATE TO THE PARTY?
YES, SIMILAR TO MR. PERRY'S
COMMENTS, WE HAD AN OPPOSE IN
THE PREVIOUS VERSION, AND WE'RE
TAKING A LOOK AT IT AND PROBABLY
BE ABLE TO REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION
AS WELL, HOPEFULLY AT LEAST
JOINT SPOUSE WILL BE INCLUDED.
THANK YOU. OKAY. WITH THAT, WE
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE DAIS
FOR ANY COMMENTS. CONCERNS A
MOTION. WE HAVE A MOTION TO MOVE
THE BILL BY SENATOR WIENER. MR.
PORTANTINO, WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE? I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THIS IS SORRY, SB
1160. THE MOTION IS TO PASS, AS
AMENDED, TO APPROPRIATIONS.
WAHAB SEYARTO NOT VOTING. SATO
NOT VOTING. BRADFORD. SKINNER
AYE. SKINNER. AYE. WIENER.
WIENER. AYE THAT BILL HAS HAS
TWO VOTES AND IT WILL REMAIN ON
CALL. SO AT THIS TIME, SENATOR
WIENER, YOU CAN COME UP WITH
YOUR BILL. THIS WILL BE SB 1012.
MAY BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MR. VICE
CHAIR, I'M, PRESENTING, SB 1012,
WHICH WILL PROVIDE, REGULATED
SUPERVISED ACCESS FOR PEOPLE 21
AND OLDER TO CERTAIN PSYCHEDELIC
SUBSTANCES UNDER THE SUPERVISION
OF A LICENSED AND TRAINED
FACILITATOR, IN THE BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE, I
COMMITTED TO AMEND SB TO AMEND
THIS BILL, TO LIMIT THE
LICENSURE OF FACILITATORS TO
THOSE WHO ALREADY HOLD OTHER,
CERTAIN LICENSES. SO WE LIMIT IT
TO NOT ANYONE CAN GET A LICENSE.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE AN EXISTING
LICENSE, AND WE HAVE NOT PUT
THOSE IN PRINT YET, GIVEN THE
TIGHT TIMELINE, BUT WE WILL DO
SO AT THE EARLIEST POSSIBILITY,
SB 1012 IS A NARROWER VERSION OF
LEGISLATION THAT THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED LAST YEAR, SB 58, WHICH
WOULD HAVE BROADLY
DECRIMINALIZED PERSONAL
POSSESSION AND USE OF CERTAIN
PSYCHEDELIC SUBSTANCES,
TRAGICALLY, THE GOVERNOR VETOED
SB 58, BUT IN HIS VETO MESSAGE,
HE CONSTRUCTIVELY CALLED ON THE
LEGISLATURE TO SEND HIM A BILL
FOCUSED ON THERAPEUTIC USE OF
PSYCHEDELIC USE. WE IMMEDIATELY
GOT TO WORK ON SB 1012 LAST
FALL, WORKING WITH A BROAD RANGE
OF STAKEHOLDERS, INCLUDING, THE
COALITION ON PSYCHEDELIC SAFETY
AND EDUCATION, WHICH A GROUP OF
PARENTS, THAT HAD OPPOSED SB 58,
AND WE HAVE WORKED WITH THEM AND
THEY ARE SUPPORTING THIS BILL,
AND WE WORKED WITH THEM TO
INCLUDE A FIRST OF ITS KIND
PUBLIC PRIVATE EDUCATION. FUND
TO FOSTER, TO MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE HAVE ARE EDUCATION
INFORMATION ABOUT SAFE USE OF
PSYCHEDELICS, AND AGAIN, THAT
COALITION IS NOW STRONGLY
SUPPORTING THIS BILL, SB 1012,
IS AN OVERDUE APPROACH. PEOPLE
ARE USING PSYCHEDELICS TODAY.
THERE ARE INCREDIBLE AS
INCREDIBLE POTENTIAL IN TERMS OF
TREATING MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS. AND WE
SHOULD BRING IT INTO THE
SUNLIGHT SO PEOPLE CAN USE
SAFELY IN A SUPERVISED,
STRUCTURED SETTING. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
, WITH ME HERE TODAY TO TESTIFY
ARE LIEUTENANT DAN GOLDSTEIN,
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT ACTION
PARTNERSHIP, WHICH IS A
CO-SPONSOR OF THE LEGISLATION.
AND DOCTOR BRIAN ANDERSON, A
BOARD CERTIFIED PSYCHIATRIST AT
SAN FRANCISCO GENERAL HOSPITAL
AND ASSISTANT CLINICAL PROFESSOR
AT UCSF AND FOUNDING
INVESTIGATOR AT THE UC BERKELEY
CENTER FOR THE SCIENCE OF
PSYCHEDELICS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MR. GOLDSTEIN. NICE TO SEE
YOU AGAIN. YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES,
PLEASE. PLEASURE. DISTINGUISHED
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS DAN
GOLDSTEIN. I SERVED FOR 21 YEARS
AS A POLICE OFFICER, RETIRING AS
THE FIRST FEMALE LIEUTENANT. MY
AGENCY AS A SERGEANT, I LED A
MULTI-AGENCY SPECIAL
INVESTIGATIONS UNIT THAT FOCUSED
ON NARCOTICS, GANGS AND CAREER
CRIMINALS. I'M CURRENTLY THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT ACTION PARTNERSHIP,
WHO IS ALSO A CO-SPONSOR OF THIS
BILL. POLICING PROFESSIONALS
HAVE RECOGNIZED WE CAN NO LONGER
RELY ON ARREST AS A MEANS TO
ADDRESS A PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUE.
SAVING LIVES AND REDUCING THE
CRIME AND DISORDER CAUSED BY
UNDERLYING PROBLEMATIC DRUG USE
OR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH ISSUES ARE
NOT MUTUALLY EXCLUSIVE, A
RESPONSE THAT CAN ACHIEVE BOTH
ENDS REQUIRES A PARADIGM SHIFT
TOWARDS EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICES
THAT CLOSELY LINK PUBLIC HEALTH
AND ENFORCEMENT STRATEGIES WITH
THEIR MOST IMPORTANT OUTCOMES
SAVING LIVES. FIRST RESPONDERS
THAT SUFFER FROM PTSD OR OTHER
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DISORDERS
STAND TO BENEFIT FROM ACCESS TO
THESE SERVICES. THIS IS
PARTICULARLY TRUE FOR POLICE
OFFICERS WHO SUFFER TRAUMATIC
STRESS AT A RATE FIVE TIMES
HIGHER THAN THAT OF CIVILIANS,
OR HAVE A 54% HIGHER RISK OF
SUICIDE. WE HAVE SOME OF THE
HIGHEST RATES OF SPILLOVER
VIOLENCE THAT RESULTS IN
EXCESSIVE USE OF FORCE. DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE, ALCOHOLISM AND
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER. WE OWE
IT TO THESE POLICE OFFICERS TO
ENSURE SAFER ACCESS TO
ALTERNATIVE AVENUES FOR HEALING,
SO THEY HAVE THE CHOICE TO HEAL,
RATHER THAN TO JUST NUMB
THEMSELVES TO THE DAILY TRAUMAS
THEY EXPERIENCE ON THE JOB. SB
1012 WILL CRAFT AN ACTIONABLE
PLAN FOR THE REGULATED USE OF
PSYCHEDELICS AS AN ISSUE OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. THIS BILL IS A
FIRST STEP TOWARDS SAVING LIVES
BY HELPING DISTINGUISH SIZE
CUTTING EDGE TREATMENTS FOR THE
UNDERLYING MENTAL HEALTH
CHALLENGES THAT DRIVE ADDICTION
AND OTHER BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
ISSUES, WHILE PROVIDING NEEDED
GUARDRAILS AND SAFETY TO ACCESS
TREATMENT. IN ADDITION, THERE IS
A STRONG PROVISION FOR THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF A PUBLIC
EDUCATION FUND TO EDUCATE THOSE
WHO ARE CURRENTLY OR IN THE
FUTURE WILL BE USING
PSYCHEDELICS ON THE RISK AND
BENEFITS OF THESE SUBSTANCES.
THIS BILL DOES NOT DECRIMINALIZE
PSYCHEDELICS, BUT FROM A PUBLIC
SAFETY PERSPECTIVE OF THE CITIES
AND JURISDICTIONS AND STATES
THAT HAVE IMPLEMENTED THERAPY
THERAPEUTIC MODELS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. NEXT
SPEAKER. YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
ALSO THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. MY
NAME IS DOCTOR BRIAN ANDERSON.
I'M A PUBLIC PSYCHIATRIST AND A
SCIENTIST WHO STUDIED THE
MEDICAL AND NON-MEDICAL USES OF
PSYCHEDELICS FOR OVER 15 YEARS.
MY RESEARCH IS FUNDED BY
PHILANTHROPY AND THE FDA. AND MY
WORDS TODAY REPRESENT MY OPINION
AND NOT THOSE OF MY INSTITUTION.
I AND OTHER CLINICIANS AND
SCIENTISTS HAVE WORKED WITH
SENATOR WEINER'S OFFER OFFICE TO
DRAFT SB 1012 BECAUSE IT
ADDRESSES AN IMPORTANT PUBLIC
HEALTH ISSUE. WE KNOW FROM THE
US FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THAT
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS USE
PSYCHEDELICS EVERY YEAR. THEIR
HEALTH AND SAFETY CAN BE
IMPROVED BY HAVING ACCESS TO A
STATE REGULATED SYSTEM THROUGH
WHICH THEY CAN ACCESS, SAFETY
SCREENING, INFORMED CONSENT
PREPARATION, THÀNH, SUPERVISED
USE, AND FOLLOW UP. I THINK THAT
SB 1012 COULD DECREASE STIGMA
REGARDING PSYCHEDELIC USE AND
MAKE IT EASIER FOR PATIENTS TO
TALK TO THEIR DOCTORS ABOUT
THEIR USE, AS WELL AS MAKE IT
EASIER FOR HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS
TO PROVIDE COUNSELING ON SAFE
PSYCHEDELIC PRACTICES. THIS BILL
WOULD SET A NATIONAL PRECEDENT
FOR HOW A STATE REGULATED
PSYCHEDELIC FACILITATION SYSTEM
COULD PRIORITIZE PUBLIC
EDUCATION, AS WELL AS MAKE IT
EASIER TO HOPEFULLY COLLABORATE
WITH OTHER FORMS OF CONVENTIONAL
LICENSED HEALTH CARE AND, MOST
IMPORTANTLY, IMPROVE THE SAFETY
OF THE MANY AMERICANS, AND
PARTICULARLY CALIFORNIANS, WHO
WILL BE CHOOSING TO USE
PSYCHEDELICS IN NON-REGULATED
SETTINGS, PARTICULARLY NON FDA
REGULATED MEDICAL SETTINGS, IN
THE FUTURE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. AT THIS TIME, WE'LL
TAKE A PRIMARY. WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. ANY PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. MR.
SHERMAN, YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS.
RYAN SHERMAN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
NARCOTIC OFFICERS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION, AS WELL AS ALL THE
POLICE AND DEPUTY SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATIONS LISTED IN THE
ANALYZES, WE REMAIN CONCERNED
ABOUT AND OPPOSED TO SB 12 1012.
AND HOWEVER WE SUPPORT THE
EFFORTS TO HELP VETS AND FIRST
RESPONDERS SUFFERING FROM PTSD.
REGRETTABLY, NOTHING IN THIS
BILL HAS TO DO WITH VETS, FIRST
RESPONDERS, OR PTSD. THERE'S NO
REQUIREMENT LIMITING THIS BILL
AND THE ACCESS TO THE
PSYCHEDELICS TO VETS AND FIRST
RESPONDERS. THERE'S NO
REQUIREMENT LIMITING THIS BILL
TO PERSONS SUFFERING FROM PTSD.
IN FACT, NO MEDICAL MENTAL
HEALTH DIAGNOSIS OF ANY KIND IS
REQUIRED BEFORE A PERSON CAN BE
GIVEN ECSTASY. AYAHUASCA,
MUSHROOMS OR MESCALINE. NO
MEDICAL HISTORY REVIEW BY A
DOCTOR IS REQUIRED. NO
MEDICATION CONFLICT CHECK IS
REQUIRED BY A DOCTOR. THE
FACILITATORS ESTABLISHED UNDER
THIS BILL ARE NOT REQUIRED TO BE
MEDICAL DOCTORS, ALTHOUGH SOME
MEDICAL DOCTORS MAY SEEK TO
BECOME A FACILITATOR, PURSUANT
TO THE BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE HEARING ALCOHOL AND
DRUG COUNSELORS WOULD BE
PERMITTED TO BE THESE
FACILITATORS EVEN THOUGH THEY
DON'T HAVE, ADVANCED TRAINING OR
DEGREES OR MEDICAL LICENSE. MANY
OF THE ALCOHOL AND DRUG
COUNSELORS ARE ADDICTS AND
ALCOHOLICS THEMSELVES, HAVING
THEM OVERSEE THE DISPENSING,
DISPENSING OF PSYCHEDELICS IS
JUST MEAN, TEMPTING THEM TO
RELAPSE. IN CLOSING, THERE'S NO
PTSD OR MEDICAL OR MENTAL HEALTH
DIAGNOSIS FROM A MEDICAL
PROFESSIONAL DOCTOR REQUIRED.
THERE IS NO MEDICAL DOCTOR OR
PROVIDING SUPERVISION OR OR
PRESCRIBING THESE DRUGS TO
DISPENSE THESE CHEMICAL ONE OR
SCHEDULED ONE DRUGS. EXCUSE ME,
THAT ARE PRONE TO ABUSE. FOR
THESE REASONS, WE REMAIN
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THE BILL IN
PRINT. THANK YOU. DO YOU HAVE
ONE SECOND LEFT? THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. DO WE HAVE ANOTHER
WITNESS IN PRIMARY OPPOSITION?
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES. GREAT.
THANK YOU. CHAIR MEMBERS. MY
NAME IS GREG BURT FROM THE
CALIFORNIA FAMILY COUNCIL. AND
WE ALSO HAVE GRAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT THE HARM THIS BILL WILL
CAUSE TO OUR STATE CITIZENS. AS
THE PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE, YOU
ARE CHARGED WITH THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF KEEPING PUBLIC
SAFE FROM DRUGS CONSIDERED
DANGEROUS AND HARMFUL. OUR STATE
AND FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
ALREADY SET UP AN ELABORATE,
WELL-REGULATED SAFETY SYSTEM
THAT INCLUDES SCIENTIFIC TESTING
AND WELL-EDUCATED DOCTORS AND
PHARMACISTS TO ENSURE THAT THE
DRUGS SOLD AND USED BY THE
PUBLIC FOR MENTAL ILLNESS MEET
HIGH STANDARDS FOR SAFETY AND
EFFECTIVENESS. SENATOR WIENER,
HERE IS HERE TODAY SAYING THAT
THOSE SAFETY STANDARDS ARE TOO
HIGH FOR A PARTICULAR DRUG
CATEGORY. DRUGS CALLED
PSYCHEDELICS. HE THINKS THESE
DRUGS DESERVE A SPECIAL
EXEMPTION FROM ALL THE SAFETY
RULES THAT EVERYONE ELSE HAS TO
FOLLOW. HE HAS CREATED NEW
PROTOCOLS FOR OVERSIGHT THAT, IN
MY OPINION, SIMPLY GIVE THE
APPEARANCE OF SAFETY, BUT IN
REALITY REMOVE SOUND SCIENCE
FROM THE EQUATION. THE BILL
ENABLES RECREATIONAL USE WITH
THE APPEARANCE OF MEDICAL
RESPECTABILITY. THERE IS NO
REASON TO DOUBT THE SINCERITY OF
THE VETERANS AND OTHERS
DESPERATE FOR A MEDICAL
TREATMENT FOR MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES LIKE PTSD. BUT BUT NOTICE
THAT SENATOR WIENER ISN'T
TALKING MUCH ABOUT ALL THE
VETERANS AND THOSE WITH
CONDITIONS THAT WERE ONLY MADE
WORSE BY THESE DRUGS, OR THOSE
WHO ARE RUSHED TO THE HOSPITAL
FOR HEART ISSUES, SEIZURES,
AMNESIA, ACUTE ANXIETY AND
TERRIFYING HALLUCINATIONS,
SENATOR ASHBY IN THE CHAIR OF
THE SENATE BUSINESS, PROFESSIONS
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
COMMITTEE RECOMMENDED A NO ON
THIS BILL. SHE EXPRESSED STRONG
CONCERNS. SHE NOTED THE BILL WAS
SETTING UP A COMPLETE
MARKETPLACE FOR THE DRUG, WITH
THREE NEW DEPARTMENTS OR
AGENCIES OVERSEEING PRODUCTION,
DISTRIBUTION AND SALE. I THOUGHT
WE HAD A DEFICIT. SHE ALSO
POINTED OUT THAT THAT
PSYCHEDELIC FACILITATOR DOESN'T
NEED TO HAVE A MEDICAL DEGREE OR
OVERSEE THE USE OF THESE DRUGS.
FACILITATORS ALSO HAVE NO ACCESS
TO PATIENT RECORDS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THESE THAT THE CONDITIONS
THESE PATIENTS MIGHT HAVE MIGHT
MAKE THESE DRUGS MAKE THINGS
WORSE. LOCAL JURISDICTIONS HAVE
NO LOCAL POWER OVER REGULATING
THESE FACILITATORS LIKE THEY DO
WITH MARIJUANA. TWO MINUTES.
SORRY AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY TODAY. OKAY AT THIS
POINT, WE WILL TAKE METOOS FOR
PEOPLE THAT ARE IN OPPOSITION OR
ARE IN FAVOR OF THE BILL. PLEASE
COME UP, STATE YOUR NAME, STATE
THE ORGANIZATION YOU REPRESENT
AND WHETHER YOU OPPOSE OR
SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR, AND MEMBERS. ANTHONY
MOLINA, ON BEHALF OF HEROIC
HEARTS PROJECT NEW APPROACH
ADVOCACY, THE STEINBERG
INSTITUTE AND THE SACRAMENTO
INSTITUTE FOR PSYCHOTHERAPY AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, Dð COONEY ON
BEHALF OF ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU. JULIE
NIELSEN WITH THE NATIONAL UNION
OF HEALTHCARE WORKERS WITH THE
PROMISED AMENDMENTS AND SUPPORT.
ALICE MICHAEL, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION, IN SUPPORT. MR.
CHAIRMAN, MEMBERS CORY SALZILLO,
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION, IN
OPPOSITION. CÁC DIRECTOR OF
POLICY FOR VETERANS EXPLORING
TREATMENT SOLUTIONS. AND WE ARE
A CO-SPONSOR OF THE BILL AND
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. DYLAN ELLIOTT, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF PSYCHIATRISTS.
AND WITH YOUR VERY BRIEF
INDULGENCE, MISTER VICE CHAIR, I
JUST WANT TO EXPRESS WE REMAIN
CONCERNED WITH THE BILL, BUT
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR HIS
CONTINUED EFFORTS IN WORKING
WITH US, INCLUDING WITH RESPECT
TO OUR MEETING NEXT WEEK. THANK
YOU. PHIL MELENDEZ, SMART
JUSTICE CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
HEY, IS THERE ANYBODY ELSE THAT
WANTS TO COME UP? IF THERE
ISN'T, WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO
THE DAIS FOR QUESTIONS. I MOVE
THE BILL. OKAY. WE HAVE A MOTION
BY SKINNER TO MOVE THE BILL. I
HAVE SOME QUESTIONS. OKAY. SO
YOU AND I HAVE TALKED ABOUT THIS
BILL BEFORE BECAUSE I HAVE GRAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT EXPANDING THE
ABILITY FOR PEOPLE TO ALTER
THEIR MINDS AND THEN GO OUT INTO
THE PUBLIC WITH THEIR ALTERED
MENTAL STATUS, AS A FORMER
PUBLIC SAFETY PROFESSIONAL, I AM
WELL AWARE OF THE PTSD ISSUES
THAT ARE PERVASIVE IN BOTH
POLICE AND FIRE DEPARTMENTS, AS
WELL AS THE EXTREME ISSUES WITH
A LOT OF OUR MILITARY PEOPLE
THAT ARE COMING BACK AND OUR
VETERANS, IN TALKING TO THEM,
WHILE THEY DO SEEK TREATMENT,
THEY DO NOT SEEK TO BE MADE THE
POSTER CHILDREN FOR THESE TYPE
OF EXPANSIVE, BILLS, AS SOME OF
THE TESTIMONY I HEARD TODAY,
FRANKLY, CONCERNS ME BECAUSE IT
GOES BEYOND WHAT I HAD TALKED TO
YOU ABOUT WAS A VERY, VERY
NARROW WINDOW, FOR TREATMENT OF
PTSD AND OTHER PSYCHOSES THAT
WERE PREVIOUSLY UNABLE TO BE
TREATED WITH OTHER METHODS. AND
AND, AND IT HAD TO BE DONE UNDER
A DOCTOR'S SUPERVISION, THIS
DIDN'T SOUND LIKE A DOCTOR'S
SUPERVISION. IT SOUNDS LIKE A
LICENSED CLINICIAN TYPE OF
SITUATION, WHICH AND THEN ALSO
DURING THE TESTIMONY I HEARD
FROM YOUR WITNESSES THAT THIS IS
MORE OF AN EFFORT TO ENABLE IT
TO GO ON A WIDER SCALE FOR
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO JUST USE IT
AND AT LEAST THEY'LL HAVE TO BE
SUPERVISED. THE PROBLEM I HAVE
AND IN MY EXPERIENCE WITH PEOPLE
THAT HAVE TAKEN PSYCHEDELICS, IS
THAT, THERE ARE OCCASIONALLY
TIMES WHEN THEY HAVE A VERY
DELAYED RESPONSE OR A RECURRENCE
OF THE PSYCHEDELIC THAT THEY MAY
HAVE TAKEN BEFORE. AND SO WHILE
THEY MAY BE UNDER SUPERVISION
DURING THE IMMEDIATE TIME
PERIOD, THEY MAY HAVE A RELAPSE
OUT IN THE PUBLIC, THAT MAY BE
MISCONSTRUED AND CREATE AN
INCIDENT WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT.
AND WHEN THOSE GO BAD, WE ALL
KNOW WHAT HAPPENS, SO I AM NOT
AT A COMFORT LEVEL WITH YOUR
BILL, THAT THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT HAS MORE BENEFITS, I WANT
IT NARROWED WAY DOWN TO WHERE IT
IS AN EXTREME, TREATMENT BY A
DOCTOR, AND, AND THAT'S, YOU
KNOW, WHERE WE NEED IT LIMITED.
I DO NOT FEEL THAT IT IS
BENEFICIAL FOR THE PUBLIC TO
HAVE MORE PEOPLE THAT THAN WE
ALREADY HAVE, THAT HAVE ALTERED
MENTAL STATUSES. AND ALSO, THE
OTHER CONCERN I HAVE IS THAT'S
ALSO A VERY GOOD WAY TO GET OUT
OF A CRIME, IS TO SAY THAT
YOU'RE UNDER THE INFLUENCE OF
SOMETHING AND YOU DIDN'T KNOW
WHAT YOU WERE DOING, AND, AND
THAT'S NOT GOOD ENOUGH FOR ME,
SO IN ORDER TO MAINTAIN PUBLIC
SAFETY, I AM I'M GOING TO HAVE
TO OPPOSE THIS BILL. AND I'M
SORRY, BECAUSE I REALLY YOU
KNOW, I WANTED THAT EFFORT FOR
THE PTSD STRICKEN AND EXTREME
CASES WHERE THAT MAY HELP
BECAUSE THERE ARE CASES WHERE IT
DID THE OPPOSITE AND IT TURNED
PEOPLE SCHIZOPHRENIC. I READ ON
THOSE, AND SO, YOU KNOW,
SOMETIMES IT HELPS AND SOMETIMES
IT DOESN'T, BUT IT HAS TO BE
DONE UNDER DOCTOR'S SUPERVISION.
AND I DON'T THINK THAT THIS DOES
THAT. THANK YOU, Þ. AND WITH
THAT YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU,
MR. VICE CHAIR. I APPRECIATE
YOUR, THOUGHTFUL FEEDBACK AND
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITIES
THAT WE'VE HAD TO SPEAK ABOUT
THIS. AND I DEFINITELY WILL STAY
IN TOUCH, COLLEAGUES, I YOU
KNOW, I THINK WE NEED TO BE VERY
CLEAR THAT RIGHT NOW, AS WE
SPEAK, MANY PEOPLE ARE USING
PSYCHEDELICS. SOME USE IT
RECREATIONALLY, SOME ARE USING
IT TO SAVE THEIR LIVES. WE HAVE
A WHOLE COALITION OF VETERANS,
FIRST RESPONDERS. WE HAD A
FIREFIGHTER AT OUR LAST HEARING
WHO WE HAD A NINE OVER 11
FIREFIGHTER FLY OUT HERE FOR THE
LAST HEARING ON THE PREVIOUS
VERSION OF THE BILL LAST YEAR,
THESE FOLKS ARE TELLING US THAT
THESE SUBSTANCES ARE SAVING
LIVES AND RIGHT NOW THEY'RE
FACED WITH A CHOICE OF EITHER
COMMITTING A CRIME TO HEAL
THEMSELVES OR LEAVING THE
COUNTRY TO HEAL THEMSELVES. WE
SHOULD NOT BE PUTTING PEOPLE IN
THAT POSITION. WE SHOULD BE
BRINGING THIS INTO THE SUNLIGHT
WITH REGULATED FACILITIES AND
SUPERVISED STRUCTURED USE WITH
SAFETY EVALUATION OPTIONS THAT
WILL MAKE IT SAFER THAN IT IS
TODAY. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. ALL RIGHT. AND WITH
THAT, THIS IS SB 1012. MOTION IS
Dð TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
WAHAB SATO. NO. SATO. NO.
BRADFORD SKINNER. AYE. SKINNER.
AYE. WIENER. AYE. WIENER. AYE
OKAY. THAT BILL REMAIN ON CALL.
THANK YOU. SENATOR. MR. VICE
CHAIR, I'M ALSO PRESENTING A
SHORT BILL FOR SENATOR STERN,
WHO IS OUT TODAY. MISS
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS, DO YOU HAVE
TIME FOR HIM TO PRESENT ANOTHER
BILL FOR. IF YOU'RE IN A RUSH,
YES. THAT'S FINE. OKAY. I'LL
DEFER TO THE SENATOR. THANK YOU.
I APPRECIATE THAT. SENATOR
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS, WELCOME. WILL
BE PRESENTING SB 1282. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. YOU MAY BEGIN
WHEN READY. THANK YOU, MR. VICE
CHAIR. AND THANK YOU,
COLLEAGUES, GOOD MORNING. I AM
SO THRILLED TO BE PRESENTING SB
1282, AND I WILL BE TAKING THE
COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENTS. AND I
WANT TO THANK, THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR HELPING TO WORK WITH
US ON THIS, ON THIS BILL, SB
1282 IS A CRUCIAL PIECE OF
LEGISLATION WHICH WOULD REQUIRE
COUNTIES TO DEVELOP DIVERSION
PROGRAMS FOR THEFT RELATED
OFFENSES AND PROVIDE JUDGES WITH
THE ABILITY TO OFFER DIVERSION
THÀNH, FOR NONVIOLENT FELONY
OFFENSES. THE EFFECTS OF MASS
INCARCERATION DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACT BLACK AND BROWN
COMMUNITIES LIKE THOSE IN MY
DISTRICT SOUTH CENTRAL LOS
ANGELES IN PARTICULAR, COMES TO
MIND. AND ALTHOUGH BLACK PEOPLE
IN MY COUNTY REPRESENT ONLY 6%
OF THE STATE'S POPULATION, THEY
COMPRISE 30% OF THOSE, AS WELL
AS OTHER BLACK FOLKS ACROSS THE
STATE IN OUR PRISON INDUSTRIAL
COMPLEX, NOT ONLY DOES
INCARCERATION DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECT OUR MOST VULNERABLE,
STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THAT
INCARCERATION HAS OFTEN FAILED
TO DECREASE CRIMES IN OUR
COMMUNITIES WITH RE-ARREST RATES
AS HIGH AS 68% IN SOME
JURISDICTIONS. EVEN FURTHER, A
2021 ANALYSIS THAT LOOKED AT
OVER 116 STUDIES FOUND THAT
SPENDING TIME BEHIND BARS IN OUR
COUNTRY EITHER HAVE NO EFFECT ON
A PERSON'S FUTURE OR PUTS THEM
AT MORE RISK OF INCREASING
CRIME. DESPITE THE CONTINUED
RELIANCE ON INCARCERATION IN OUR
JUSTICE SYSTEM, DATA HAS SHOWN
THAT PUTTING PEOPLE BEHIND BARS
FAILS TO ADDRESS THE SYSTEMIC
ISSUES THAT DRIVE CRIME. AND FOR
FAR TOO MANY, THE ROOT CAUSES
ARE CRIME OR POVERTY,
HOMELESSNESS, UNEMPLOYMENT AND
LACK OF OPPORTUNITIES. DIVERSION
PROGRAMS OFFERS AN EFFECTIVE
ALTERNATIVE. IT DRIVES
INDIVIDUALS AWAY FROM
INCARCERATION AND TOWARD
REHABILITATION, LIKE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES, DRUG TREATMENT,
HOUSING, AND JOB TRAINING AND
PLACEMENT PROGRAMS. AND WE KNOW
THESE ARE THE THINGS THAT
TRANSFORM LIVES, AND THESE ARE
THE THINGS THAT MAKE OUR
COMMUNITIES SAFE. STUDIES HAVE
ALSO FOUND THAT THROUGHOUT THE
STATE AND NATION, DIVERSION
PROGRAMS HAVE YIELDED FAR LOWER
RE-ARREST RATES, AS LOW AS 4,
AND HAS DECREASED RECONVICTION.
AND ULTIMATELY, THAT SAVES THE
STATE MONEY. YOU KNOW, IT COSTS
US ABOUT $150,000 A YEAR TO
HOUSE SOMEONE IN OUR PRISONS BY
AVOIDING COSTS OF HOUSING
INDIVIDUALS IN OUR PRISONS AND
DECREASING TIME FOR OUR COURTS.
DIVERSION PROGRAMS OFFER
VALUABLE MEANS TO ADDRESS COST
PRESSURES AS WELL AS BUILD A
REHABILITATIVE AND JUSTICE
SYSTEM THAT SAVES LIVES AND OUR
COMMUNITIES. IN A BUDGET YEAR
WHERE WE ARE STRUGGLING AND
SEARCHING FOR WAYS TO MAKE THE
ENDS MEET HERE IN THE STATE, HOW
DO WE DECREASE BEDS IN OUR
PRISONS AND JAILS AND USE
DIVERSION AS A WAY TO OFFER
UNIQUE OPPORTUNITIES TO ADDRESS,
THESE CONDITIONS THAT FUEL CRIME
AND HOPEFULLY BUILD BETTER
NEIGHBORS? AND WHILE THESE
PROGRAMS HAVE PROVEN TO BE
EXTREMELY SUCCESSFUL AT REDUCING
CRIME IN OUR COMMUNITIES, IT IS
UNFORTUNATE THAT FAR TOO MANY
INDIVIDUALS HAVE FOUND
THEMSELVES INELIGIBLE FOR
REFERRAL INTO DIVERSION PROGRAMS
BY EXPANDING JUDICIAL DISCRETION
TO OFFER DIVERSION AS AN
ALTERNATIVE TO INCARCERATION AND
NONVIOLENT FELONY OFFENSES, WE
CAN ENSURE OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM IS
DOING BETTER IN ADDRESSING THE
ROOT CAUSES OF CRIME AND HELPING
TO BUILD UP SAFER COMMUNITIES.
THIS BILL IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE
WE CAN NOT REQUIRE JUDGES TO
OFFER DIVERSION AND NONVIOLENT
CASES. BUT THIS BILL SIMPLY
REQUIRES THAT COUNTIES MAKE
THESE PROGRAMS AVAILABLE FOR
THEFT OFFENSES AND PROVIDES
JUDGES WITH AN ACCESS TO TOOLS
TO HELP ADDRESS CRIME IN A REAL
WAY. WITH ME TODAY ARE JUDGE
DANIEL LOWENTHAL FROM CALIFORNIA
SUPERIOR COURT IN LOS ANGELES,
AND ESMA MOORE, A SOCIAL WORKER
WITH THE REENTRY SUPPORT TEAM,
REST HERE IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY
WHO WORKS WITH THE CONFLICT
CRIMINAL DEFENDERS OFFICE. ALL
RIGHT, MR. LOWENTHAL, THANK YOU.
IF YOU WANT TO SPEAK AS A
PRIMARY WITNESS, YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. I APPRECIATE THAT. IN
2014, THE LEGISLATURE CONFERRED
THE JUDGES IN L.A. COUNTY DURING
A THREE YEAR PILOT PROGRAM THAT
WAS IN EFFECT FROM 2015 TO 2018,
WITH DISCRETION TO DIVERT ALL
MISDEMEANANTS DURING THAT THREE
YEAR PERIOD, L.A. COUNTY
DIVERTED ROUGHLY 5600 PEOPLE,
OVER 95% OF WHOM SUCCESSFULLY
COMPLETED ALL DIVERSIONARY TERMS
AND CONDITIONS, AND LEFT THEIR
ENCOUNTER WITH THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM WITHOUT A DEBILITATING,
LIFELONG CRIMINAL CONVICTION.
RECIDIVISM WAS VIRTUALLY
NEGLIGIBLE, ALL FAR LOWER THAN
THOSE WHO WERE TRADITIONALLY
PROSECUTED AND INCURRED A
CONVICTION AND A SIGNIFICANT
COST SAVINGS WAS ACHIEVED BY
L.A. COUNTY. THROUGH TRIALS
AVOIDED, WE WENT FROM ABOUT 3200
MISDEMEANOR JURY TRIALS IN
FISCAL YEAR 2014 TO ABOUT 900
FISCAL YEAR 2017. BASED ON THE
SUCCESS OF THE L.A. PROGRAM, YOU
EXPANDED THE ABILITY TO
DISCRETION TO DIVERT. YOU MADE
IT STATEWIDE AND PERMANENT. AND
THAT WAS IN 2021. THE ANECDOTAL
EVIDENCE SUGGESTS THAT
STATEWIDE, WE HAVE ACHIEVED AS
MUCH SUCCESS AS L.A. DID DURING
THE PILOT PROGRAM. NOW I'M
ASKING THAT YOU EXPAND THAT
DISCRETION THÀNH TO DIVERT TO
FELONY CASES. IT MIGHT BE THE
CASE THAT THE MAJORITY OF FELONY
CASES ARE NOT DIVERSION
APPROPRIATE, BUT IN A STATE WITH
OVER 40 MILLION PEOPLE AND WHERE
OVER 200,000 FELONY CASES ARE
FILED EVERY YEAR, THERE WILL BE
SOME THAT ARE APPROPRIATE FOR
DIVERSION. THIS BILL IS NOT
DOESN'T DIVERT A SINGLE PERSON.
IT'S SOLELY CONFERS JUDGES WITH
DISCRETION TO IMPLEMENT
DIVERSION WHEN IT IS IN THE
INTEREST OF JUSTICE, AND IT
ADVANCES PUBLIC SAFETY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR KEEPING TO
ONE MINUTE AND 55 SECONDS. NEXT
SPEAKER. WE HAVE ANYBODY ELSE
WHO WANTS TO SPEAK AS A PRIMARY
WITNESS IN FAVOR OF THE BILL.
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES, MA'AM.
THANK YOU, MY NAME IS ISMA
MOORE. I'M A SOCIAL WORKER FOR
THE SACRAMENTO COUNTY CONFLICT
CRIMINAL DEFENDER'S OFFICE
REENTRY SUPPORT TEAM. THE
REENTRY SUPPORT TEAM WAS CREATED
IN JUNE OF 2023 TO HELP ADDRESS
THE UNDERLYING NEEDS OF THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE POPULATION BY
ASSESSING INDIVIDUALS FOR MENTAL
HEALTH, SUBSTANCE USE, AND
HOUSING SUPPORT THROUGH
DIVERSION AND COLLABORATIVE
COURT PROCESSES. IN JUST TEN
MONTHS, 797 CLIENTS WERE
REFERRED TO OUR REST TEAM. OF
THOSE, 211 HAD THEFT RELATED
FELONY CHARGES, AND OF THOSE
211, 97 HAD EITHER SUBSTANCE
USE, MENTAL HEALTH OR HOUSING
INSTABILITY. MANY HAD A
COMBINATION OF ALL THREE. I WILL
ILLUSTRATE WITH AN EXAMPLE. WE
HAVE AN AFRICAN AMERICAN MALE
WHO IS 22 YEARS OLD AND WAS
CHARGED WITH THE FELONY OF
RECEIVING STOLEN PROPERTY AFTER
BEING FOUND SLEEPING IN A STOLEN
CAR AS A CHILD. HE STARTED USING
MARIJUANA AT THE AGE OF SEVEN,
LOST HIS FATHER AT THE AGE OF
TEN, AND NEVER COMPLETED HIGH
SCHOOL SINCE THE AGE OF 16, HE
WAS LIVING IN THE STREETS,
DIAGNOSED WITH BOTH COGNITIVE
AND MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES. DCJ
WAS GRANTED DIVERSION AND
FINALLY HAS A MENTAL HEALTH
PROVIDER AND STABLE HOUSING.
SIMILARLY, WE HAVE JP, A 40 YEAR
OLD HISPANIC MALE WHO WAS
CHARGED WITH FELONY GRAND THEFT
AS A CHILD. HE GREW UP WITH A
MOTHER WHO WAS ADDICTED TO DRUGS
BY THE AGE OF SIX, HE WAS IN AND
OUT OF GROUP HOMES IN THE FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM. AT THE AGE OF
SEVEN, HE ATTEMPTED TO KILL
HIMSELF AND HAD HIS FIRST
PSYCHIATRIC ADMISSION. HE LATER
TRIED COMMITTING SUICIDE FIVE
MORE TIMES. BY THE AGE OF TEN,
HE WAS USING METH DAILY.
DIAGNOSED WITH BOTH HEARING
IMPAIRMENT SUBSTANCE USE AND
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES, JP WAS
ULTIMATELY GRANTED DIVERSION AND
GIVEN AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
RESIDENTIAL REHABILITATION. FOR
THE FIRST TIME IN HIS LIFE. HE
IS SINCE DOING WELL. THESE ARE
JUST SOME EXAMPLES OF HOW
EXPANDING THEFT, DIVERSION TO
FELONIES AND ALLOWING COURTS TO
REFER TO MENTAL HEALTH,
SUBSTANCE USE AND HOUSING
SUPPORT CAN HELP PUBLIC SAFETY
AND MEET THE UNDERLYING NEEDS OF
INDIVIDUALS. AS, WE WORK WITH
INDIVIDUALS AND A COOKIE CUTTER
APPROACH DOES NOT WORK FOR
EVERYONE, IT'S IMPORTANT TO
CEASE THE REVOLVING DOOR OF
INCARCERATION AND MOVE FORWARD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MA'AM.
OKAY, AT THIS POINT, WE WILL
TAKE, PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. I KNOW EVERYBODY IS
GETTING EXCITED, SO PRIMARY
WITNESSES AND OPPOSITION,
ANYBODY GOING ONCE, TWICE SOLD
AT THIS. NOW WE WILL GO ON AND
MOVE ON TO PEOPLE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO, DO THEIR METOOS, THIS IS FOR
PEOPLE IN OPPOSITION OR IN FAVOR
OF THE BILL. JUST PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME, THE ORGANIZATION YOU
REPRESENT, AND WHETHER YOU
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE THE BILL.
THANK YOU. ALICE MICHAEL, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION AND STRONG
SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING, CLAIRE
SIMONICH VERA, INSTITUTE OF
JUSTICE. WE ARE PROUD TO SPONSOR
AND SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. DANICA O'DONNELL, ON BEHALF
OF INITIATE JUSTICE AND LAW
DEFENSE AND STRONG SUPPORT, Dð
COONEY ON BEHALF OF ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION AND STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, SENATOR
JOANNA WILLIAMS WITH LEGAL
SERVICES FOR PRISONERS WITH
CHILDREN IN STRONG SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING, JOSH STICKNEY, ON
BEHALF OF THE ELLA BAKER CENTER
FOR HUMAN RIGHTS AND STRONG
SUPPORT. FOR SMART JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT.
LAURENCE COX ALL OF US ARE NONE.
STRONG SUPPORT. GILBERT ANTHONY
MURILLO, LSPC. AND ALSO NONE.
STRONG SUPPORT. KRISTEN
SCHLUSSEL, SACRAMENTO COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S ASSOCIATION IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. ALYSSA
MOORE. LEGAL SERVICES PRISONERS
FOR CHILDREN. STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO. ALL RIGHT. DO WE
HAVE ANY LEAD OPPOSITION? ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. ME TOO IS IN
OPPOSITION. I'M ASSUMING YOU
GUYS. THANK YOU. SO WE'RE GOING
TO BRING YOU BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SEEING NONE.
SENATOR, WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
? I WOULD I WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU TO THOSE WHO GAVE TESTIMONY
AND SUPPORT THE BILL. I THINK
THIS IS A COMMON SENSE LAW. IT'S
JUST EXPANDING THE TOOLBOX THAT
OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM HAS TO MEET
THE NEEDS OF OUR COMMUNITIES AND
TO MAKE CALIFORNIA A TRULY
SAFER. AND WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. AND I JUST WANT TO MAKE IT
CLEAR BECAUSE I KNOW I WAS
PRESENTING, BUT YOU HAVE
ACCEPTED THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS, RIGHT? I HAVE, THANK
YOU. AND I WANT TO MAKE IT CLEAR
TO THE PUBLIC, FOR THE MOST
PART, THIS COMMITTEE REALLY DOES
WANT TO REMOVE AND BE VERY
STRICT ON VIOLENT OFFENDERS AND
THOSE WHO COMMIT SEXUAL ACTS. SO
I APPRECIATE THAT. WITH THIS, I
ASK FOR A MOTION, SENATOR WIENER
HAS MOVED THE BILL, CAN WE CALL
A ROLL CALL? VOTE SB 1282. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED,
TO APPROPRIATIONS WILL HAVE A
JOB. I SAY ARTO SATO. NO.
BRADFORD SKINNER, WIENER WIENER.
I THANK YOU, SO THAT BILL IS ON
CALL. THANK YOU. SENATOR, WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO SENATOR WILK
. YES. THANK YOU. GOOD TO SEE
YOU AGAIN, MADAM CHAIR. ALL
RIGHT, MADAM CHAIR, MEMBERS, I
FIRST WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR
AND HER COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
DILIGENTLY WORKING WITH US ON
THIS BILL. AND THAT BEING SAID,
I'M HAPPY TO ACCEPT ALL THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. SB 1359
WILL PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED RELIEF
FOR RURAL AREAS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA THAT HAVE BEEN
DECIMATED FROM TRUCK OWNER SLASH
OPERATORS DUMPING WASTE
MATERIALS THROUGHOUT OUR
COMMUNITIES. UNREGULATED DUMPING
HAS WREAKED HAVOC ON OUR
COMMUNITIES, RESULTING IN SEVERE
ENVIRONMENTAL POLLUTION AND
UNSAFE LIVING CONDITIONS. IT HAS
BEEN SUCH A PERSISTENT PROBLEM
BECAUSE PROPERTY OWNERS AND
TRUCK OPERATORS HAVE BEEN
EXPLOITING A LEGAL LOOPHOLE.
CURRENTLY, PERMITS ARE REQUIRED
TO DUMP OR RECEIVE WASTE
MATERIALS ANYWHERE OTHER THAN
LICENSED FACILITIES UNLESS IT
INCURS OCCURS ON PRIVATE
PROPERTY WITH THE OWNER'S
PERMISSION. CONSEQUENTLY, TRUCK
TRUCKERS HAVE BEEN PAYING
PRIVATE PROPERTY OWNERS A FEE TO
USE THEIR PROPERTY AS A DUMP
SITE TO AVOID THE HIGH COST OF A
LICENSED FACILITY. WHILE
PROPERTY OWNERS POCKET THE
MONEY. SB 1359 CLOSES THE
LOOPHOLE BY REQUIRING A PERMIT
FOR DUMPING ON PRIVATE PROPERTY,
WITH OR WITHOUT THE OWNER'S
PERMISSION. THE BILL ALSO
INCREASES MANDATORY FINES AND
MAKES ILLEGAL DUMPING A
MISDEMEANOR RATHER THAN JUST AN
INFRACTION. THESE MEASURES WILL
FINALLY PROTECT COMMUNITY
MEMBERS FROM BAD ACTORS WHO HAVE
PROFITED FROM DESTROYING THEIR
NEIGHBORHOODS WITHOUT FEAR OF
ANY CONSEQUENCE. FURTHERMORE,
THE REGION'S WERE DUMPING CURVES
ARE NOT WEALTHY COMMUNITY.
COMMUNITIES, AND VERY OFTEN ARE
DISADVANTAGED, DECENT MANAGED
COMMUNITIES. I KNOW FOR ME, I'VE
GOT TWO AREAS OF PARTICULAR,
LAKE LOS ANGELES, WHICH IS IN
EASTERN, L.A. COUNTY, UP IN THE
HIGH DESERT, IT'S GOT A
POPULATION OF 11.3% AFRICAN
AMERICAN AND ALMOST 54%
HISPANIC. AND ANOTHER AREA IS
SUN VILLAGE, WHICH I'M ASHAMED
TO SAY IS WHERE AFRICAN
AMERICANS WERE FORCED TO BUY
HOMES AND LIVE DURING THE 50S. I
DON'T THINK THAT END UNTIL 1960.
SO IT'S ALL, AFRICAN AMERICAN.
AND THOSE PLACES ARE JUST
DECIMATED WITH WITH JUNK THAT
THESE KIDS HAVE TO WALK THROUGH
TO, TO, TO GET TO SCHOOL. SO
WITHOUT ADEQUATE PUNISHMENTS FOR
THOSE EXPLOITING OUR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AS
LITERAL DUMPING GROUNDS, THESE
INDIVIDUALS WILL CONTINUE TO
RUIN THE ENVIRONMENT AND
NEGATIVELY AFFECT OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS. WE HAVE TWO,
SPEAKERS THIS MORNING. WE HAVE
JOHN KENNEDY WITH THE CRC AND
ADAM HARPER WITH CAL SEMA. AND
WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU, TO
THE WITNESSES AGAIN, YOU'LL
APPROACH THE LECTERN, YOU WILL
BE TIMED AT TWO MINUTES. OKAY.
GOOD MORNING JOHN KENNEDY. WITH
RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA. WE REPRESENT 40 OF
THE STATE'S 58 COUNTIES, MANY
HAVE 50 TO 90% FEDERAL LANDS,
VERY LOW POPULATION DENSITIES,
SOMETIMES BETWEEN 1 AND 10
PERSONS PER SQUARE MILE. ILLEGAL
DUMPING IS A HUGE PROBLEM IN
RURAL AREAS, LAKE SANTA BARBARA,
MONTEREY COUNTY, MANY OTHER
COUNTIES, LÀ COUNTY, MANY
UNINCORPORATED AREAS, EVEN
WITHIN CITIES. THIS IS A PROBLEM
ON LOCAL LAND, STATE LANDS,
FEDERAL LANDS, AND WE HAVE A
GOOD HANDLE. THERE'S A SUCCESS
STORY ON MATTRESSES, BUT THAT'S
ONLY BECAUSE YOU ALL ESTABLISHED
THIS PRODUCER RESPONSIBILITY
ORGANIZATION FOR MATTRESSES FOR
THE REST OF THE MATERIAL. IT'S A
REAL CHALLENGE TO MANAGE TO FIND
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE RESPONSIBLE
FOR IT. AND SO, WE APPRECIATE
THIS BILL IN CONJUNCTION WITH
SOME OTHER STATE GRANT PROGRAMS
THAT EXIST. IT WILL PROVIDE MORE
TOOLS FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
OTHERS TO COMBAT ILLEGAL
DUMPING. IT CLOSES THE LOOPHOLE
THAT THE SENATOR MENTIONED,
INCREASES PENALTIES FOR REPEAT
OFFENDERS. THESE PENALTIES WERE
LAST INCREASED IN 2006, AND SO
IT'S OUR PERSPECTIVE THAT THE
INCREASES ARE OVERDUE AND IT
ALLOWS THE STATE OR LOCAL AGENCY
WITH JURISDICTION OVER THE
PROPERTY, TO DECLARE THIS
DUMPING TO BE A NUISANCE. THAT
CAN BE PARTICULARLY USEFUL FOR
STATE AGENCIES WITH PROPERTY AND
POTENTIALLY ALSO SPECIAL
DISTRICTS. SO FOR THOSE REASONS,
WE APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING THE
BILL TODAY. WE APPRECIATE YOUR
INTEREST IN ILLEGAL DUMPING AND
PROVIDING US TOOLS AND URGE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR SB 11. I'M SORRY.
1359 THANK YOU. CHAIR MEMBERS
ADAM HARPER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRIAL
MATERIALS ASSOCIATION, WE'RE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL WITH THE
AMENDMENTS. WE REALLY APPRECIATE
THE SENATOR AND, SENATE'S
EFFORTS TO COMBAT ILLEGAL
DUMPING. IT'S A SIGNIFICANT
PROBLEM, WE APPRECIATE CLARITY
ON WHO CAN RECEIVE AND THAT THE
LEGAL BUSINESSES THAT ENGAGE IN
MOVING ROCK, CONCRETE, ASPHALT
CAN CONTINUE TO DO SO. SO THANK
YOU. IT'S AN IMPORTANT PROBLEM.
WE APPRECIATE THE SENATE'S
EFFORTS TO CLEAN THIS UP. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO LEAD OPPOSITION. TWO
MINUTES. THANK YOU ALICE MICHAEL
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION,
OUR CONCERN WITH THIS BILL IS
THAT ILLEGAL DUMPING IS ALREADY
COVERED BY THE STATE LAW. THE
CONCERN IS THAT THIS BILL
SPECIFICALLY CRIMINALIZES, THE,
SUBJECTS, INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
INVOLVING, INVOLVED IN THE
TRANSPORT OF THE, PRODUCTS THAT
THEY COULD BE SUBJECT TO
CRIMINAL PENALTIES, THIS
SUBJECTS DAY WORKERS WHO MAY BE
HIRED BY THIRD PARTY CONTRACTORS
, WHO MAY BE UNFAMILIAR WITH THE
LAW OR EVEN ULTIMATELY, WHAT'S
BEING DONE WITH THE PRODUCT THAT
THEY'RE ASKED TO MOVE, THAT THEY
COULD BE SUBJECTED TO PENALTIES
BECAUSE OF THE WAY THIS BILL IS
WRITTEN AS THE COMMITTEE IS WELL
AWARE, OUR CRIMINAL LAWS TEND TO
OVER INCARCERATE BROWN AND BLACK
. MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY.
THESE PEOPLE, DAY LABORERS,
OFTEN COME FROM THESE
COMMUNITIES AND WE ARE CONCERNED
THAT THIS BILL WILL BE USED TO
PROSECUTE, DAY LABORERS WHO ARE
UNFAMILIAR WITH THE LAW AND ARE
NOT THE ONES MAKING THE
DECISIONS THÀNH TO DO THE
ILLEGAL DUMPING. THANK YOU.
REMOVED AS PART OF THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. I DON'T KNOW. Dð
COONEY WITH ACLU, CALIFORNIA
ACTION AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION, FIRST AS CAN YOU
WRITE IT DOWN SO I COULD SAY THE
PREVIOUS WITNESS NOTED, IT IS
ALREADY UNLAWFUL TO TRANSPORT
WASTE MATTER, ROCK, CONCRETE,
ASPHALT AND DIRT FOR THE PURPOSE
OF DUMPING ON A PRIVATE PROPERTY
WITHOUT THE OWNER'S CONSENT. SO
AS LONG AS THE PERSON
TRANSPORTING THE MATERIALS HAS
THE SPECIFIC INTENT TO COMMIT
THE CRIME, THE PERSON CAN BE
CONVICTED OF ATTEMPTED DUMPING
AND DUMPING. UNDER THE CURRENT
LAW, IF A PERSON TRANSPORTING
THESE MATERIALS DOES NOT POSSESS
THE SPECIFIC INTENT TO DUMP THEM
, THAT PERSON SHOULD NOT BE
GUILTY OF A CRIME, WHETHER AS AN
ATTEMPT UNDER CURRENT LAW OR AS
A NEW CRIME PROPOSED UNDER SB
1359. SECOND, WHILE THE GOAL OF
ENCOURAGING PEOPLE TO SEEK
APPROPRIATE PERMITS AND LICENSES
TO DEPOSIT WASTE AND OTHER
MATERIALS ON PRIVATE PROPERTY IS
WORTHWHILE, FAILURE TO DO SO
DOES NOT RISE TO THE LEVEL OF A
CRIME. SUCH FAILURES ARE MORE
APPROPRIATELY ADDRESSED THROUGH
PROFESSIONAL REGULATIONS AND IN
FACT ARE UNDER EXISTING LAW.
LASTLY CRIMINALIZING BOTH THE
PROPERTY OWNER AND THE PERSON
WHO DEPOSITED THE MATERIALS,
WHEN IT IS LIKELY THAT NEITHER
WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR OBTAINING
THE PERMIT OR LICENSE, AND MAY
NOT KNOW WHETHER A PERMIT OR
LICENSE WAS PROPERLY OBTAINED,
WILL NOT ACTUALLY ADDRESS OR
DETER THE BEHAVIOR CONTEMPLATED
BY THIS BILL, AND INSTEAD THE
CRIMINAL CONVICTIONS AND
INCREASED MANDATORY FINES MAY
MADE NEEDLESSLY FALL, FALL ON
THOSE WELL-INTENTIONED PROPERTY
OWNERS AND INNOCENT LOW WAGE
WORKERS WHO CANNOT AFFORD THE
FINES, AND WHOSE INABILITY TO
PAY THE FINES WILL HAVE LASTING
CONSEQUENCES FOR THEM AND THEIR
FAMILIES. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. DO WE HAVE ANY METOOS
ON EITHER SIDE? STATE YOUR NAME,
YOUR ORG YOU OPPOSE OR YOU
SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT. SEEING NONE,
AS FAR AS I JUST WANT TO SAY
THIS, JUST TO CLEAR IT UP WITH
OPPOSITION, THE AUTHOR ACTUALLY
TOOK AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS SOME
OF THE CONCERNS. MORE
SPECIFICALLY, THAT, YOU KNOW, IF
YOU HAVE NONCOMMERCIAL AMOUNTS,
FOR DUMPING YOU, THAT HAS BEEN
REMOVED. SO I JUST WANT TO BE
VERY CLEAR THAT WE HAVE NARROWED
THE SCOPE OF THE BILL, ENSURING
THAT, YOU KNOW, WE ARE NOT
TARGETING SPECIFIC COMMUNITIES
OR PUTTING PEOPLE AT RISK, AND I
DO APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR FOR
ACCEPTING THOSE AMENDMENTS. IF I
HAVE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK ON THIS, SENATOR SATO,
THIS IS PRETTY EASY, THOSE AREAS
THAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT ARE
VERY IMPACTED BY THIS, AND IT'S
BECAUSE OF ITS REMOTE LOCATION.
AND, AND, AND THE INABILITY FOR
PEOPLE TO BE HELD RESPONSIBLE
SOMETIMES. AND SO THE EASIEST
WAY TO NOT GET FINED FOR ILLEGAL
DUMPING IS TO NOT ILLEGAL DUMP,
AND SO THAT LANDS ON THE PERSON
THAT KNOWS DARN WELL THAT
THEY'RE ILLEGALLY DUMPING
MATERIAL, SO I WILL SUPPORT YOU,
BILL. AND I MOVE THE BILL. AT
THIS TIME, I'M SURE YOU HAVE
SIMILAR SITUATIONS AS I DO, AND
THAT WE'RE CLOSE TO WHERE RURAL,
BUT WE'RE CLOSE TO THE METRO
AREA. AND I WILL TELL YOU THIS.
AND I DON'T WANT TO,
PARTICULARLY WHEN THEY WERE
BUILDING SOFI STADIUM, THEY
PEOPLE WERE OUT THERE ILLEGALLY
DUMPING ALL THE TIME THE
CONSTRUCTION MATERIALS FROM
THERE. YES. MOST OF INGLEWOOD IS
NOW IN LAKE LOS ANGELES. YES
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE? I JUST AGAIN, I
WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR AND THE
COMMITTEE. I'D LIKE TO INVITE
THE OPPONENTS. SO THEY WANT TO
COME TO MY DISTRICT AND SEE ONE.
WHAT THEY WHAT YOU HAVE TO WALK
THROUGH. AND THEN TWO, MEET MY
CONSTITUENTS THAT ARE BLACK AND
BROWN. I DON'T KNOW ABOUT ALL
THE OTHER RURAL DISTRICTS, BUT
MINE CERTAINLY, REP REPRESENT
THOSE COMMUNITIES. AND WITH
THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR CERRO. CAN WE
HAVE A ROLL CALL, PLEASE? SB
1359 MOTION. MOTION IS DUE. PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
WAHAB. AYE. AYE. SATO. SATO AYE.
BRADFORD. SKINNER. SKINNER. AYE.
WIENER WIENER. AYE. THANK YOU.
AND CAN WE, LIFT THE ROLL. FOR
EVERYBODY, I JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE EVERYBODY'S ON EXCEPT ONE.
YEAH. SO LET'S START FROM THE
BEGINNING. FIRELIGHTER NUMBER
ONE THAT WAS BEEN DISPENSED
WITH. ALL RIGHT, THAT BILL IS
OUT DISPENSED WITH. NUMBER TWO,
FILE ITEM. WE JUST NEED
BRADFORD. OKAY FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE. OKAY. NUMBER FOUR. NUMBER
FIVE. AND MYSELF INCLUDED. SORRY
SB 970. MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
3 TO 0. WAHAB AYE. WAHAB. AYE.
OKAY. ITEM NUMBER SIX, CONSENT
IS. CONSENT IS DONE, FILE NUMBER
EIGHT, MOTION SB 1057. MOTION IS
TO PASS, AS AMENDED, TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
2 TO 0. WAHAB. AYE. AYE STEVE
BRADFORD, THAT BILL IS ON CALL,
FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE, SB 1132.
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
FLOOR. CURRENT VOTE IS 3 TO 0.
WAHAB, A WAHAB AYE FILE ITEM
NUMBER THAT BILLS ON CALL FILE.
ITEM NUMBER TEN SB 1160. MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED, TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE 2
TO 0. WAHAB. AYE. AYE NUMBER 11,
BRADFORD. OKAY. NUMBER 12, SB
1282. MOTION IS TO PASS, AS
AMENDED, TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 2 TO 1. SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE. ALL RIGHT. NUMBER
13, BRADFORD. OKAY. NUMBER 16.
WE'RE DONE WITH THAT ONE. OKAY.
NUMBER 17, SB 1012. MOTION IS Dð
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT
VOTES 2 TO 1. WAHAB I'M GOING TO
BE A NO. WAHAB NO. WE NEED. ALL
RIGHT, SO THAT BILL IS ON CALL.
AND HAVE WE DONE NUMBER 19? WE
HAVE NOT DONE THE VOTE ALL NIGHT
, AND I HAVE TO. I'M PRESENTING.
YES, WE'RE. SO LET'S DO 19.
LET'S PULL BRING IN 19. DO WE
HAVE A MOTION. MOTION ON
ARCHULETA AS AMENDED. CAN WE GET
A MOTION ON NUMBER 19. SO MOVED.
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED, SB 1262
BY SENATOR WIENER. ROLL CALL
VOTE ARCHULETA FOR. YEAH. NO,
NO. THE MOTION HAS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR WIENER FOR SB 1262 BY
SENATOR ARCHULETA. CAN WE HAVE A
ROLL CALL? VOTE. MOTION IS TO
PASS, AS AMENDED. WAHAB. AYE
WAHAB. AYE. SATO. SATO AYE.
BRADFORD. SKINNER. WIENER.
WIENER AYE. ALL RIGHT, THAT
BILLS ON CALL, WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE SB 1400 BY SENATOR STERN,
BUT SENATOR STERN IS OUT. SO
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE SENATOR
WIENER PRESENT. NO WORRIES.
OKAY. SO SINCE WE HAD, A LITTLE
BIT SWITCHEROO, WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE A FILE ITEM NUMBER 15, SB
1472 BY SENATOR LIMÓN. THANK
YOU. CHAIRS AND COLLEAGUES, SB
1470 1472 ESTABLISHES THE
CALIFORNIA FIREARMS DO NOT SELL
LIST, A VOLUNTARY SYSTEM FOR
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS TO ADD
THEIR NAME TO THE CALIFORNIA DO
NOT SELL FIREARMS, WHICH
PROHIBITS AN INDIVIDUAL FROM
LAWFULLY PURCHASING A FIREARM.
61% OF GUN DEATHS ARE SUICIDES
WITH PEOPLE BETWEEN THE AGES 35
AND 64 ACCOUNTING FOR 46.8% OF
ALL SUICIDES IN THE COUNTRY. SB
1472 WOULD REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO CREATE
AN ACCESSIBLE SYSTEM FOR
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS TO
VOLUNTARILY ADD THEIR NAMES TO
THE CALIFORNIA DO NOT SELL LIST
FOR FIREARMS. SB 1472 ALLOWS
INDIVIDUALS WHO VOLUNTEER TO
REGISTER TO BE TO REMOVE THEIR
NAMES FROM THE LIST AS WELL.
TODAY WITH ME, WE HAVE OUR SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY SHERIFF, BILL
BROWN AND DYLAN ELLIOTT ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF PSYCHIATRISTS, TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU. YOU CAN APPROACH THE
LECTERN. YOU WILL HAVE TWO
MINUTES. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
MEMBERS, I'M SANTA BARBARA
COUNTY SHERIFF BILL BROWN AND
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION. ONE OF THE BILLS
SPONSORS. THE NEXUS BETWEEN
FIREARMS AND SUICIDE IS WELL
ESTABLISHED. CALIFORNIA FACES A
PRESSING PUBLIC HEALTH CHALLENGE
OF PEOPLE EXPERIENCING SUICIDAL
IDEATION AND THEIR ACCESS TO
FIREARMS. RAIMES THE ABSENCE OF
AN ACCESSIBLE AND VOLUNTARY
MECHANISM FOR PERSONS TO EXCLUDE
THEMSELVES FROM BEING ABLE TO
LAWFULLY PURCHASE A FIREARM DUE
TO SUICIDAL IDEATION IS A
CRITICAL IS A CRITICAL
DEFICIENCY IN THE EXISTING
LEGISLATIVE FRAMEWORK. WE
APPRECIATE OUR CONVERSATIONS
WITH COMMITTEE STAFF AND
ACKNOWLEDGE, AS THE ANALYSIS
POINTS OUT, THAT WE HAVE WORK TO
DO IN TERMS OF GETTING MORE
DETAIL INTO THE BILL LANGUAGE.
WE ARE NOT LOOKING TO
CRIMINALIZE ANY PERSON WHO HAD
ADD THEMSELVES TO THE LIST, AND
ONLY THE PERSON THEMSELF COULD
ADD OR REMOVE THEMSELVES TO OR
FROM THE LIST. WE ARE COGNIZANT
OF PRIOR EFFORTS TO DO SOMETHING
IN THIS SPACE AND THE CHALLENGES
SPECIFICALLY RELATED TO
INTEGRATING THIS EFFORT INTO
WHAT DOJ CURRENTLY OVERSEES IN
TERMS OF FIREARMS DATABASES,
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE DOJ
TO TRY TO COME UP WITH AN
APPROACH HERE THAT ALLOWS US TO
ACCOMPLISH OUR POLICY GOALS
WITHOUT CREATING UNDUE FISCAL
PRESSURE, AND WE BELIEVE THAT WE
HAVE FOUND A PATH TO DO JUST
THAT. THREE OTHER STATES,
VIRGINIA, UTAH AND WASHINGTON,
HAVE LAWS SIMILAR TO THIS. IN
WASHINGTON, ALMOST 100 PEOPLE
HAVE PLACED THEMSELVES ON THEIR
DO NOT SELL LIST. EXTRAPOLATING
THAT NUMBER FOR CALIFORNIA'S
POPULATION ESTIMATES THAT ABOUT
500 PEOPLE MIGHT AVAIL
THEMSELVES OF THIS OPPORTUNITY
IF IT'S OFFERED HERE IN OUR
STATE. WE STRONGLY BELIEVE LIVES
WILL BE SAVED. IF CALIFORNIA
FOLLOWS THE EXAMPLE SET BY OTHER
STATES. LASTLY, I WANT TO
RECOGNIZE AND THANK THE PERSON
WHO BROUGHT THE NEED FOR THIS
LEGISLATION TO OUR ATTENTION.
SHE IS A PROFESSIONAL HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WHO STRUGGLES WITH
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES. SHE
ENTERED A DARK PERIOD OF HER
LIFE WHEN SHE BATTLED SEVERE
DEPRESSION AND BEGAN TO
CONTEMPLATE SUICIDE WITH A
FIREARM. WORRIED THAT SHE MIGHT
ACT UPON THOSE THOUGHTS, SHE
ATTEMPTED TO HAVE HERSELF PLACED
ON THE PROHIBITED PERSONS LIST
VOLUNTARILY, BUT FOUND AFTER
MANY PHONE CALLS TO STATE
AGENCIES AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THAT THERE WAS
CURRENTLY NO WAY TO DO THAT, SHE
APPROACHED THE STATE'S MENTAL
HEALTH OVERSIGHT SERVICES,
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT
AND ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION,
ON WHICH I SERVE AS A
COMMISSIONER, AND ASKED FOR HELP
IN FILLING THIS GAP. SHE WAS
RELUCTANT TO SPEAK TODAY
PUBLICLY OUT OF CONCERN THAT
SELF-DISCLOSURE OF HER MENTAL
ILLNESS MIGHT ADVERSELY IMPACT
HER EMPLOYMENT, BUT NONETHELESS,
HER COURAGE IN REACHING OUT WITH
HER SITUATION AND BECOMING THE
GENESIS OF THIS LATEST ATTEMPT
TO CREATE SUCH A POLICY IS
COMMENDABLE. WE APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE'S FAVORABLE
CONSIDERATION OF SB 1472 AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU, THANK YOU. NEXT
GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS DYLAN
ELLIOTT HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
PSYCHIATRISTS TO SHARE OUR
STRONG SUPPORT AS COAUTHORS OF
SB 1472. AS HAS BEEN MADE QUITE
CLEAR, THERE'S STRONG EVIDENCE
THAT ACCESS TO FIREARMS IS
ASSOCIATED WITH AN INCREASED
RISK OF SUICIDE. SUICIDES MAKE
UP 52% OF ALL FIREARM DEATHS IN
OUR STATE, AND MORE THAN ONE,
EXCUSE ME, AND MORE THAN ONE
THIRD OF ALL SUICIDES IN
CALIFORNIA ARE BY FIREARM. IN
2019, THERE WERE NEARLY 1400
FIREARM SUICIDE DEATHS IN
CALIFORNIA, 54 OF WHICH WERE
CHILDREN AND TEENS. PREVENTION
IS POSSIBLE A RECENT STUDY FOUND
THAT CLOSE TO A THIRD OF THE
GENERAL POPULATION AND MORE THAN
40% OF THOSE WITH PREVIOUSLY
DIAGNOSED MENTAL HEALTH
CONCERNS, WOULD ADD THEIR NAME
TO A DO NOT SELL LIST IF THEY
HAD THE OPTION. THE UTMOST
PRIORITY OF KSAP AND ITS MEMBER
PRACTITIONERS IS PATIENT CARE
AND SAFETY. WHILE WE EXPECT IT
WOULD PREVENT MUCH MORE HARM IF
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF THIS
DATABASE WERE TO SAVE JUST ONE
LIFE, IT WOULD BE WELL WORTH IT.
CSEPP. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND WE URGE YOUR
AYE VOTE TO ENACT THIS COMMON
SENSE VOLUNTARY PROGRAM. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESSES SEEING NONE
, WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO ME
TO BOTH IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION. PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME, YOUR ORG AND THAT YOU
EITHER SUPPORT OR OPPOSE.
THEY'RE SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE PROSECUTORS ALLIANCE AND
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. DO WE
SEE ANY OTHERS SEEING NONE.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. NO
CONVERSATION. MOVE THE BILL. ALL
RIGHT. SENATOR LIMÓN, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR WIENER
HAS MOVED THE BILL. CAN WE HAVE
A ROLL CALL VOTE, PLEASE? SB
1472, MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. WAHAB THANK YOU.
I HAVE I SEE BRADFORD SKINNER
WIENER WIENER. AYE. ALL RIGHT.
THAT BILL IS ON CALL. THANK YOU.
SENATOR, SENATOR WIENER IS GOING
TO BE PRESENTING FINAL ITEM
NUMBER 14 ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
STERN, SB 1400. SENATOR WIENER,
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, MADAM CHAIR. AS
NOTED, I AM PRESENTING SENATE
BILL 1400 ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
STERN. THIS BILL WILL REMOVE THE
EXPRESS STATUTORY AUTHORITY FOR
COURT TO DISMISS A CASE IN WHICH
A MISDEMEANOR DEFENDANT IS FOUND
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL AND
INSTEAD REQUIRE THE COURT TO
DETERMINE IF THE DEFENDANT IS
ELIGIBLE FOR DIVERSION OR OTHER
TREATMENT OPTIONS, SUCH AS A
CARE PROGRAM, CONSERVATORSHIP OR
ASSISTED OUTPATIENT TREATMENT.
THE AUTHORS OFFICE IS COMMITTED
TO CONTINUING CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL, ACLU,
STEINBERG INSTITUTE, DISABILITY
RIGHTS, CALIFORNIA, AND OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS TO CREATE THE MOST
EFFECTIVE BILL POSSIBLE.
ACCORDING TO THE AUTHOR, THIS
BILL CLOSES A LOOPHOLE IN HIS
BILL FROM 2021 SB 317, WHICH
OFFERED MISDEMEANOR DEFENDANTS
FOUND INCOMPETENT TO STAND
TRIAL. THE ABILITY TO GET CREDIT
FOR TIME AND TREATMENT IN LIEU
OF JAIL TIME. SINCE THE PASSAGE
OF SB 317 JUDGES HAVE DISMISSED
THOUSANDS OF THESE CASES WITHOUT
A TREATMENT PLAN OR ANY ABILITY
FOR THE COURTS OR COUNTIES TO
MAINTAIN CONTACT. FOR EXAMPLE,
THE LA COUNTY OFFICE OF
DIVERSION AND REENTRY REPORTS
THAT AT LEAST FIVE OF THESE
CASES DEFENDANTS ARE RELEASED
PER WEEK WITH NO TREATMENT OR
CONNECTION TO SERVICES, AS SB
1400 WILL ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIANS FOUND INCOMPETENT
TO STAND TRIAL, HAVE ACCESS TO
TREATMENT, AND FOLLOW UP CARE
THAT THEY NEED. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
DO WE HAVE ANY LEAD WITNESSES
SEEING NONE, DO WE HAVE LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESSES? SEEING
NONE? DO WE HAVE METOOS IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION? PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME, YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND THAT YOU
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE. KEARNEY WITH
ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION. WE ARE
NOT IN OPPOSITION, BUT WE ARE
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE
ON AMENDMENTS AND LOOKING
FORWARD TO THOSE CONVERSATIONS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ALEX.
MICHAEL, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION, WE ALSO, ARE
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR AND APPRECIATE THE
DISCUSSIONS AND LOOK FORWARD TO
FURTHER DISCUSSION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. KRISTEN SCHLUSSEL
SACRAMENTO COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION, WE ARE ALSO AN
IN-BETWEENER AND WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR AND HIS
STAFF ON AMENDMENTS, AND WE
APPRECIATE THEIR WILLINGNESS TO
WORK WITH US. THANK YOU. SEEING
NO OTHERS AND SEEING NO COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. SENATOR,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE ON
BEHALF OF SENATOR STERN, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO WAIT ON A MOTION UNTIL
ONE OF THE SENATORS ARE BACK, WE
ARE NOT ALLOWED TO MAKE A MOTION
ON THE BILL THAT WE PRESENT, NOR
ARE WE ALLOWED TO AS CHAIR. SO
JUST GIVING YOU GUYS A HEADS UP
ON THE RULES, THAT'S THE LAST
.
ONE OF THE BEST. CAN WE LIFT THE
CALLS? THAT'S A GOOD AIRPORT.
ARE YOU READY? WE'RE DONE WITH
THAT ONE. SO, ITEM TWO, SB 926.
MOTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
4 TO 0. BRADFORD BRADFORD. AYE.
THAT THAT BILL'S OUT. ITEM THREE
SB 935. BECKER MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 3 TO 0.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD. I ZERO.
THAT'S OUT THE 4 TO 0 THAT BILLS
OUT ITEM 412 SB 1254. MOTION IS
DUE. PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 3 TO 1. BRADFORD
BRADFORD I IS OUT. THAT BILL IS
OUT. ITEM FIVE SB 970 MOTION IS
DUE. PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 4 TO 0.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD I. BILLS OUT
THAT. BILLS OUT. SENATE CONSENT
ITEM EIGHT SB 1057 MOTION IS TO
PASS, AS AMENDED, TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
3 TO 1. BRADFORD MENGIBAR. SHE
TOOK SOME AMENDMENTS. BRADFORD I
4 TO 1 THAT BILLS OUT. ITEM NINE
SB 1132. MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
THE FLOOR. CURRENT VOTE IS 4 TO
0. BRADFORD BRADFORD I SAID THAT
BILL IS OUT 5 TO 0. ITEM TEN SB
1160. MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 3 TO 0.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD I. 3 TO 1 I
KNOW HE WAS A NOT VOTING OH YEAH
HE DID NOT VOTING. NO NO HE'S
NOT VOTING. HE WAS NOT VOTING.
YEAH OKAY. SORRY THAT BILL IS
OUT. ITEM 11 SB 1267 MOTION IS
DUE. PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 4 TO 0. BRADFORD
BRADFORD I WAS OUT. YEAH. SEE
THAT BILL IS OUT. ITEM 12 SB
1282 MOTION IS DUE. PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 3 TO 1.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD I. THAT BILL
IS OUT AS WELL. SB 1359 MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED, TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
4 TO 0. BRADFORD. BRADFORD I.
THAT BILL IS OUT. SB 1400
MOTION. WE NEED A MOTION. OH,
YES, WE NEED A MOTION. SENATOR
WIENER AND SENATOR WAHAB CAN'T
MAKE A MOTION. SENATOR BRADFORD,
BECAUSE. CAN YOU MAKE A MOTION
ON THIS BILL? BUT NO, YOU CAN
MAKE THE MOTION. MOTION ALL
RIGHT. I MEAN, SENATOR WIENER.
SO MOVED BY BRADFORD, CAN WE
HAVE A ROLL CALL VOTE? SB 1400,
MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WILL HAVE A
WAHAB. I SAY, I SAY I, BRADFORD,
BRADFORD I SKINNER WIENER I
WIENER I WE GOT TO WAIT FOR
SKINNER THAT BILLS ON CALL ITEM
15 SB 1472. MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
2 TO 0. SEYARTO I SATO I
BRADFORD. BRADFORD I SKINNER TO
LEAVE THAT ONE OPEN THAT BILLS
ON CALL STILL WITH THAT ONE ITEM
17 SB 1012. MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
THREE. NOW TWO TO 2 TO 2.
BRADFORD BRADFORD I THAT BILLS
OUT. THAT AND THE SB ITEM 19 SB
1262. MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 3 TO 0.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD I LET ME SEE.
ALL RIGHT. CAN WE GET SKINNER
HERE TRYING
.
LET'S LIFT THE CALL FOR SENATOR
SKINNER. ITEM 14 SB 1400. MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 4 TO 0. SKINNER.
AYE. SKINNER AYE. THAT BILLS OUT
. ITEM 15, SB 1472. MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 4 TO 0. SKINNER.
SKINNER. AYE OH, THAT BILLS OUT.
AND THEN ITEM 19 SB 1262. MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED, TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
4 TO 0. SKINNER. SKINNER. AYE
THAT BILL IS OUT. WE ARE DONE.
THE SENATE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE HAS IS ADJOURNED.
THANK YOU